And we're live.
Dave Rubin trying to shut this fucker.
Shut that fucking thing off for two
seconds.
We're here to celebrate the fact that
Chris Christie got kicked off of a quiet
train this morning for talking on his
phone while drinking a McDonald's
strawberry shake.
And this is the guy who wants to band
pot about band yourself.
You fucking Slob.
How dare you.
How dare he drink a McDonald's
strawberry shake in public and have
everything.
Not only that,
after having a stomach stapled.
Yeah,
it,
it didn't really take.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just those bitches out.
You can do.
You have to do saying you think he's
doing something.
I just keep eating.
You just keep piling through.
I know a guy was blown through two of
them.
He's had it done twice and blown through
a both times.
So you actually like tear open the
staples like is that I,
you know,
I haven't done any Mris operations on
these people.
We are going to go heavy medical stuff
today,
but it's been explained to me,
Dave Rubin,
the skin is flexible and if you just
keep stretching that bitch out,
it's clearly when these people,
like I have a friend and his friend,
his friend of mine as well,
but a good friend of his and he was
about,
he's about to go do this and I said,
please try to talk them out of it
because you don't need surgery.
He just needed to change your life
because the surgery is only going to fix
the physical aspect of it.
There's a reason while you're stuffing
all this sugar and fat and you're just.
You were addicted to food,
so you need to find out what it is,
what's going on.
So you're talking about the
psychological.
I think that's where it's really at.
I don't think it is the physical thing.
I think the physical thing is a
manifestation of a psychological issue
for sure.
You get physically addicted to shitty
food.
Like I quit sugar recently.
Shouldn't say quit sugar because I had a
little this weekend,
so I don't.
I didn't quit it,
but I,
I removed it from my primary diet and I
quit it all together for two weeks and
what happened to me five days in was
really shocking because I had a massive
headache like five days in.
The cravings were freaky and my head was
killing me and it's like snapples and
protein bars and low fat milk.
There's all this shit that has sugar in
it.
You think of granolas healthy and then I
would look at him like 20 grams of sugar
in a serving of grunt and I usually have
two servings.
You look,
it's not even sugar.
What we do,
we do in America,
we do high fructose corn syrup to
illuminate you on this,
but in our coke and our can of coke,
because it's cheaper to put corn in it,
to sweeten it.
We're drinking corn instead of sugar.
That's why people get Mexican cokes.
You know what I mean?
You go to a fancy restaurant here in la,
they give you a Mexican coke because
that has real sugar.
Think how just warped our whole system
is the core thing.
We can do five hours on corn because
corn is,
you know,
it's in,
it's in wallpaper,
it's an everything to mazing and you
know,
you're trying to get off sugar,
but what you're really trying to get
off his corn,
there's definitely that as well.
Um,
but I,
I think,
um,
even just simple sugar,
so like even like I read this one thing,
it's like a,
I forgot what the product was,
but it was one of the ingredients was
pure cane sugar.
Like you're selling me something
amazing.
Pepsi now,
pure cane sugar,
like holy shit,
sugar,
it's still sugar,
but it's still.
Your body doesn't necessarily
differentiate.
It still shows us salt,
you know,
like,
that's,
that's how dumb,
that's how dumb people have become about
food.
We were talking a little bit about food
before we started,
but like it's really,
it's like the most important stuff,
what you put into your body so that then
you can function on this earth.
And we are so warped.
We got corn instead of sugar even just
now.
So I,
I told you I drank like 17 coffees
before,
but I didn't put any.
You have Stevia and everything.
I just went straight,
black,
nothing.
I've been drinking straight black lately
too,
but it's actually,
you know,
uh,
think this Guy Peter Giuliano on at one
point who's a real coffee expert.
And uh,
when you talk to a guy like that and you
talk about putting cream into coffee,
you could see his face like,
what are you doing to him?
It's,
it's a sacrilege almost.
So what would,
what would you say to drink it?
What's the best way?
Just black.
That's it.
And I've been drinking a black.
I actually prefer it in a method that
this Guy Rob Wolf created,
which is you mix it with grass fed
butter and mct oil.
The problem is for a podcast that gives
me phlegm and I stopped in the middle
and it's annoying as fuck for people
that are listening,
but it's pretty delicious.
It's very good.
Yeah.
I still do that,
but I just don't do it before podcasts
anymore.
So I did it.
I did it for about six months.
I was doing the grass fed butter and
coconut oil.
Just take a teaspoon of coconut oil and
it's amazing and you feel great and it's
delicious and all that.
But I did over the course of about six
months,
I probably gained like eight pounds from
all the butter.
It's,
it's a lot of calories to be plowing and
morning,
but he does do some good things.
I think it has something to do with how
the caffeine actually ingests into your
body.
It slows it down so you don't get that
burst of energy crash and all that,
which was all great.
But you know,
eight pounds in six months.
That is a lot to gain.
Most people,
adults,
their appetite and your appetite.
Um,
no,
not really.
I don't give up.
I live in West Hollywood.
I,
there's a certain amount of working out
I have to do and not,
not Joe Rogan level,
but you know,
uh,
it's uh,
just to stay in the neighborhood.
Just certain them out.
Have you ever been to Santa Monica in
the middle of West Hollywood?
I live in the gay place on earth.
I've never seen so many daisy dukes.
It is.
It really bought well,
first of all,
I'm considered morbidly obese by these
people's standards because they starve
themselves.
I don't understand people listening.
Dave Rubin's a very slim and slender and
fit.
So the thing is,
these guys,
you know,
it's,
the gay is placed on earth and these
guys work on their bodies all day long.
You should not be carrying
a dog.
They carry their dogs,
these relapses and all this other man.
Your bicep shouldn't be bigger than your
dog.
You know what I mean?
That just shouldn't be,
shouldn't be care.
I have a pimple.
She's not,
you know,
my bicep snapped bigger than her.
I think that's a healthy way to do it.
But yeah,
in West Hollywood,
these guys,
they start,
I don't know how to.
You Starve yourself and have huge
muscles.
I just don't.
The steroids,
steroids,
that certainly helps.
You can.
There's some stuff that fighters had
been caught with that.
Uh,
I think it's called.
There's one called clenbuterol and
another called the nausea.
No,
I think.
And the idea behind any of that stuff.
The cleanse I think is supposed to like
really just lean you out.
It's a bodybuilder thing and this allows
you to keep mass on or helps you assist
you in keeping mass on when you cut
weight.
So for fighters that are trying to be
like the biggest in their weight class
right there,
dehydrating themselves,
but they want to keep as much muscle
mass as possible.
Yeah.
That can't be good for long term health.
Right.
So bad for your body.
I mean I see it with these guys and it's
like,
you know,
they're doing this just so that they can
get somebody that has a better body than
them so they can fuck.
And then they move on to the next day.
It's like this endless game.
You know what I mean?
Like I got a hot body,
he's got a high body.
I'll fuck him now.
I moved to like,
it's just this climbing this ladder.
Yeah.
It's like Icarus,
you know what I mean?
You're just going up and up and up.
But one day this thing is just going to
blow up in your face.
Yeah.
But you know,
that could be a second.
If you look at life like life is this
temporary trip,
right?
You have maybe 50 years of people
actually wanting to have sex.
You if you're fucking so lucky you take
care of everything.
So that's like from 18 to like when
you're closing in on 70,
everybody fucks.
You was just doing new charity
and that's the saddest.
That's the sadducees.
These you,
I see this,
these overly tanned hair plugged guys
that are 70 years old and they're still
at the gym hoping that that 28 year old
is looking at them and instead they're
staring at everyone and gawking at them
horribly.
It's all grow.
It's really sad.
Or we can get into this a little later,
but it's also shows me why the gay
marriage thing was so important because
these are.
I actually have a lot empathy for these
people that I can,
you know,
it's easy to make fun of,
but like if you couldn't ever enter a
relationship that then you're going to
build like what you have with your wife
where you can build a life,
you know,
and you can have kids and move forward
in life.
Well then if all you have is just
fucking,
you just keep doing it.
You not as many guys as possible
rotations,
different ones texting you all day long
trying to put it together.
Yeah,
I mean,
but figure out when you get squeezed the
time,
you know,
and it.
Exactly.
And I guess you know,
it feels good in the moment,
but for the longterm health of just like
what being human is
not so great,
but I think you know,
interestingly,
interestingly enough,
if you look at the perspective of like a
full long life,
like it's just a bunch of moments just
to like trying to maintain happiness and
a certain level as much as possible.
And you could be Chris Christie where
you're addicted to Mcdonald's shakes and
being a fat slob.
The sausage sandwiches now can advise
too much ego.
He doesn't listen or you could try to
fill yourself up with that and you know,
be married and have kids and have that
part of your life achieve normalcy.
Or You can do the Super Tan roided up
Dick Suck and rampage that,
those guys that workout at like Gold
Gold's gym on Cole.
Do you know that?
That's by.
I don't know that one,
but dude,
when I was on news radio,
we used to work out,
uh,
we used to work at sunset and gower that
was the studio and Gold's gym was right
down the street.
So sometimes we'd have off like two
hours during the middle of the day where
they had to rewrite scripts or stuff
like that.
So I'll just shoot over to goals,
get a workout and then come back.
But it is the fucking gays,
Jim.
It's not,
it's,
it's a ferocious disco is what it is.
It's just a bunch of men with scrunchy
socks on timberlands and like super
short shorts and just to tightest tank
tops.
And you walk in there like a wounded
antelope just gingerly stepping close to
the waterhole.
But how did you feel there?
Because you're,
you're in good shape but you're in good
shape,
right?
Like you care about your body,
You're doing the right things,
but you go in there and you see these
guys and you,
you does it completely.
Like,
Oh fuck.
Like I'm a fat fuck.
No,
it wasn't that at all.
I was,
I was in my twenties when I was doing
that.
This is one,
I was on news radio,
but I was.
I was fucking being targeted.
Like that was the problem.
Like guys felt like you could have 20
pounds on the bar.
Guys like I'll spot you.
Like I don't need to spot dude.
Get your fucking balls from above my
head.
Like they would literally,
you'd be on the bench and dudes would
just put their dick above your head to
grab the bar.
They just wanted their Dick in proximity
with your face.
You know like when you're doing bench
presses,
they can literally bench press with
their Cox.
This was pre Viagra to.
You got to think because this was in the
nineties,
these poor bastards were going on in the
match and when it went bad then the coc
pumps and w was the liberace movie with
Michael Douglas behind the candelabra.
Yeah,
they have.
They used to have implants,
I guess back in those days.
Those poor guys.
I had no idea we were going to start
like I didn't either.
That's the beauty of this show.
Let that bitch run for us a brief
moment.
Not,
not entirely because I can defend
myself,
but I felt what it was like to be a
woman that was pursued by men because
men are fucking gross.
Yeah,
well that's the thing.
It has nothing.
It has nothing to do with gay or
straight.
It's a man thing.
So if you happen to be a man into men.
Yes.
Well congratulations.
You just got welcome to that world and
were treated like a woman.
So I have great sympathy for women that
have to deal with this shit.
I got treated like a woman with a gun,
like,
you know,
like Oh,
okay.
All right.
Relax.
Because I wasn't vulnerable physically
because I was like stop.
Yeah.
And then it's two dudes looking at each
other and I'm like,
you know,
come on man.
Get the fuck Outta here.
It wasn't like a woman who could
physically be overpowered by this guy.
It was like a guy saying,
I'm going to kick your ass if you don't
stop trying to fuck me.
Like stop.
Were you always amazed at their
relentless,
relentless tenacity to never take a acu
Joe Rogan into it and they can never
take the cue,
right?
Yeah.
Well it's only a few guys.
Most guys would figure out that you were
straight and they were respectful.
The vast majority,
but it only takes if there's 300 guys
working out at the gym,
it only takes two guys to fuck up the
entire experience.
Less than one percent and they'll just
do it.
But those are the ones that are just
like,
they're going to go for it,
but how,
you know,
there's probably 50 other guys they're
trying to work their way into the friend
zone,
which is what women experience would.
Women experiences a bunch of guys.
I can tell you,
especially when I was younger and I was
single,
how many fucking girls that I dated who
would work with some guy who would say,
well,
Mike from the office says this is.
This is a much trying to fuck you.
Fuck you.
He's not even a real person.
Mike's wearing a Kabuki mask and he's
doing a fucking dance.
It's a mating dance.
That's not what he thinks.
This is bullshit.
Stop it.
Meanwhile,
I got to go to the gym and deal with
that Mike,
because Mike is Jesus,
but that's what I mean.
It's there's a reason why there's 7
billion of us because this,
this drive to procreate and not even on
a conscious level.
It's not like,
oh my God,
I have to get this girl pregnant and
have a baby.
It's like I got to come inside her.
You know,
I have to come.
I have to figure out how to get this
person touched my body and create
pleasure.
You don't take.
You don't take the,
the,
the objective steps to recognize,
oh,
this is a gigantic biological trick
that's been set in place by nature
because it was really hard to survive
just a few thousand years ago.
It was insanely hard to survive and you
had to make sure you meet as many people
as possible so that they made as many
people as possible.
So we can keep this retarded party going
on.
That's what it is that the end of the
day.
That's what it is.
And that's why it keeps getting dumber.
I'm sure you've seen idiocracy you're
not.
I honestly haven't seen it.
I've only seen clips of it,
but I had a bit that people accused me
of stealing from idiocracy.
But luckily I did the bit before
idiocracy came out.
So I got.
I got grandfathered in.
That's the comedians dilemma when you're
doing good shit.
So that 10 years later everyone's like,
oh,
you must have stole that.
And you're like,
no,
no.
I did that 10 years ago.
Well,
it wasn't that close.
It was just the concept that many people
have had is a dumb people or outbreeding
smart people.
Then that's the,
that's the movie mine was that explained
the pyramids.
My thing was that the idiot pyramid
workers would show up one day and go,
uh,
I was supposed to get my chuck on
Friday.
Where is everybody?
But all the smart people figured out how
to build the pyramids had already died
and that we had.
So the people just moved into the
pyramids,
like why we live in these mud houses,
we can live in the periods.
So they moved into the pyramids and
pretending they built it and it's this
long thing that sort of explains
what's going on today.
And I think that we all think at a
certain level that that's true,
that there's way more dumb people in
there are smart people and then we all
think that we benefit from people like
Elan Musk and innovators and geniuses.
But how many of them are there?
Not many.
Tiny,
tiny number.
Yeah.
Well listen,
I,
uh,
I just got gay married like a month ago.
I love what you say,
gay marriage.
Well,
first off,
people don't believe that I'm gay.
They just simply don't accept.
Why don't they accept it?
They didn't say I don't act gay.
I play sports and I don't,
you know,
like,
I got this at the gap,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not getting,
like ever comprehend Fitch and get
assaulted with that smell that they zap
you with when you walk in there.
You know,
it's funny,
I know that smell a,
I used to be afraid when I was closeted,
like in high school and college because
I didn't come out until really my mid to
late twenties,
but I used to be afraid of Abercrombie
and Fitch because they used to have
those shirtless,
you know,
like these shirtless hot guys standing
outside and I felt that they could,
that they would know,
like I just thought like these guys are
going to know that I'm standing outside
the store.
Yeah.
Oh you don't remember that.
Like even the stores at the mall,
they'd have just these shirtless guys
all,
you know,
they are all perfectly Tan.
They all look perfect and they would
just be standing there greeting you.
And to me it was like this.
Yeah,
it was like walking into a porn.
So I was afraid that they were going to
like read gay on me.
So I never,
I'm not kidding.
I don't think I've ever bought anything
from Abercrombie.
I've been there many times,
but I'd never seen never.
What year was it that they did this?
They were for a long time.
They were doing this probably in the mid
to early two thousands.
Yeah,
I know.
I probably didn't go to Abercrombie and
Fitch until the mid two thousands.
Maybe they were phasing it out,
you know,
it's really interesting.
That started as a hunting and fishing
supply company.
Yeah,
like void.
They fucking make a turn.
And then that guy,
you know,
the guy who runs it,
who's got,
he must have body dysmorphia.
So there's this guy up Jamie.
He's the one,
I don't know what his name is.
He's the one who,
uh,
he really instilled this idea that
everyone there has to look perfect and
look the same sort of.
And that's why they've had all these
lawsuits with people that are either a
little fat.
They couldn't get jobs there or I think
there was a girl who wanted to wear a
hijab or all that stuff.
And,
but if you look at this guy will pull
them up,
got so much fucking work done on his
face because he's just close to what you
said before.
He's like expressing his own weaknesses
and he's projecting them onto a
generation of kids and he's also
expressing his own confusion externally.
Whether you realize,
I mean,
look at that guy like he's had some
serious shit.
Sixty one year old CEO.
We don't need to say his name says dude
a lot.
He'll say,
oh,
this is salon.com.
First of all,
fuck,
fuck you.
I'm down with that fucking creeps.
Frauds just aggressively shitty and I
don't fight those fucking headlines.
Those tweets I had done following
because I was like,
this is such epic Shit and just such
dishonest trash like a Dave Rubin.
Why he's everything that's wrong with
gay people.
Taglia.
Exactly.
You would get those kinds of articles
and just twisting and distorting your
real positions to make social brownie
points to appeal to the hardest of
hardcore,
aggressive social justice warrior
lefties.
Can we get everybody to hate everybody?
Fucking split everybody down to just
their color and their sex to the point
where you can then control everybody
because if anyone gets out of that
little box,
there is something wrong with them.
Got Something wrong with you.
Well,
this poor guy,
he's not hanging in there.
Well,
like Robert Redford,
that motherfucker's going in there.
Well,
yeah,
he's hanging in there.
Well,
he's obviously an old dude,
but it doesn't look like a monster.
Yeah.
Like I was at,
um,
my kid has a gymnastics class and
there's this poor,
unfortunate woman who goes to this
gymnastic class who,
uh,
she looks like she's quite wealthy.
She's always dressed very well,
but she's gotten what I call monster
face and monster faces when they shoot
their face up with filler and then they
do the lips and then they pull their
face back.
So they have this sort of reptilian
mouth.
Mouth is way too big.
It's way too big.
Pull on this fucking skin.
So the opening of their mouth doesn't
match a normal person's face because
it's bigger.
It stretches like this guys,
Chris Christie stomach pulling it,
it gets bigger.
Being skin is flexible.
Think how deranged.
Really like the idea of that.
You know,
these people care about what they look
like,
right?
So they want to look better.
So they go in that first time,
they get a little botox or they get
wrestling or one of those filters,
whatever that is.
But think how the course of that changes
the way they think about everything to
the point where that woman probably
thinks she looks good.
You know what I mean?
That's,
that's an adventure in the psyche,
right?
I mean,
it's the same as bodybuilders.
It's the same as people with Anorexia.
It's the same as the guys we were
talking about before.
You know what I mean?
They just,
you just keep doing it.
No matter what you do,
you take off your shirt,
you look in the mirror and you go,
this should be a little tighter over
here,
you know?
And the woman's looking at her,
it's always the upper lip.
That's the women.
They get fat for this poor lady that I
know that had her lips done and every
time she talks to you that she's got a
scar like inside of her mouth that's
like,
it's her lip,
you know,
it's like it.
There's a line.
So like the lips never moved correctly.
Like Lisa Rena,
is that her name?
She had that thing removed right as she,
she,
she was the one that had like the crazy,
crazy,
crazy lips and I'm pretty sure about a
year ago,
uh,
she had something taken out or some
filler or something.
But I get it though,
man.
I had hair transplants when I was in my
twenties and didn't take trig.
Definitely didn't take.
Not Anymore.
I had a joke about it.
The joke was it's like taking really
healthy people and moving them into a
neighborhood where everybody's dying.
It's like we try to repopulate.
Chernobyl,
you thought you were gentrifying the
front,
but in the end you just killed more
people?
Well,
you know what it is,
man.
You keep losing hair.
So worked at first like,
oh yeah,
the parts that it was falling out.
I filled in.
We're good,
but you're not good.
You key,
it keeps,
keeps [inaudible] up.
So you did the thing where you actually
cut out.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
They cut a strip out.
How long did you let it go before you
gave up and just said,
well I had it done and then it's slow.
It was just slowly giving up and then
there's also things you can do,
like you could take Rogaine,
which kind of keeps it in,
but how funny is it when your name is
Rogan and you go into buy Rogaine?
That's,
that's ironic.
Just for that reason.
Well you probably shouldn't have been on
it because it was just dealt with it,
dealt with that,
but I'm like if it works I don't give a
shit.
And it did kind of work.
And then Propecia,
which works really well but also kills
your tick.
Yeah.
So you got,
you got a lot of.
Lot of options.
I did.
I was on probation for about six months,
about maybe seven or eight years ago and
I couldn't get a boner.
Yeah,
it's a boner killer rather than like,
I can fully say that,
but now that I shaved my head,
I actually like it way better.
It's so easy and you don't get kidnapped
by people that are cutting your hair
because uh,
I used to cut,
get my hair cut by this lady who I love
dearly,
but sometimes I'd be in a rush.
She would hold me hostage with these
fucking stories because she'd be holding
the scissors and then I told her,
you're not going to fucking talk to me
like that.
And I'd be like,
oh,
it really interesting.
Cut My fucking hair so I can run,
cut my hair so I can run away.
So basically you shaved your head
because you didn't want to listen to
this bitch?
No,
she's not.
She's not big.
She's my friend.
I love her.
But your stories are terrible,
but it's not even that.
It's just,
it's something to not think about.
It's like all of a sudden when I shaved
it,
it was like instant freedom.
Like,
Oh yeah.
And I use the back of my head as a
public service announcement.
Like if anybody's thinking about getting
a hair transplant,
I'm like,
look at my head,
let's see the scar.
You don't want one of those,
then it's not the worst thing in the
world.
Let me get this straight.
Can you swim?
Because I always see in the commercials
when they get the hair,
suddenly they can swim again.
It seems like they couldn't swim.
They had lost the ability to do the
breast stroke.
The wig commercials are the same.
And the commercials,
they're always underwater just like
fucking crazy.
So you're telling me you can still swim.
It's not as good.
I'm a little sleeker through the water,
so it's confusing,
but timing is off.
It all.
It makes no sense because the,
you see the Olympic guys,
they were the cap.
So then it makes it seem like they're
bald and they're swimming well and yeah,
you watch those commercials and then
they have a head of hair and they're
swimming well.
So it's a very confusing.
I think the idea is that if you get in
the water,
like instantly all the work that you've
done with hairspray to lock this fucking
monster and place it all evolve,
dissolves with the water and you'll
leave behind an oil slick.
But,
uh,
when you,
when you get in the water with one of
those wacky wigs hair club,
jammies,
when the idea is that you can,
nobody can tell,
nobody can tell.
Now I know you have theories on things.
Do you have a theory on hair loss?
Was it stress related for you?
It's just
purely a hundred percent.
Genetics is dihydrotestosterone.
Your body produces a derivative of
testosterone.
DHT causes your hair to fall.
I don't know why it exists in humans.
It's a strange thing and why it exists
in some and not others,
but they're,
they're like really close to fixing that
apparently with just like some sort of a
pill or a rub,
but that'll probably cause cancer or
blind in one eye.
You have diarrhea and all that shit.
Every pill we take causes 20 other
things,
you know,
I really think that they need to start.
They need to show us when they talk
about the pill,
whatever pill it is,
you got restless leg syndrome,
you got what is that?
Your legs can't stop because that real
build art is a funny bit.
I that like,
you know,
because we sit all day.
It's your body like revolting against
you,
like get the fuck up.
I wonder if like joggers get restless
leg syndrome,
not because they're actually moving.
Yeah,
I mean that would be really interesting
to study with.
Jamie,
you're a runner.
Do you ever get restless legs?
You do.
You got the late.
My whole life.
You get restless leg but you've run a
lot.
While I was moving my legs over here
feel like they need to move.
I don't know.
Wow.
Oh,
I'm not sure.
I don't.
You think they should have to show like
when they show you the pill and they and
then everyone's running in a field.
It's all that bullshit marketing
nonsense,
but then they'll say I could cause
suicidal thought they should've show
someone going through suicidal thoughts
or show somebody having diarrhea.
Like they keep doing this,
but the guys running through a field
having a helped show me what it's like
dos commercial death show a guy walking
down the boardwalk just dropping dead.
You know what I mean?
Like why are they allowed to do that?
It's such mixed messaging.
You don't understand what you're getting
yourself into chantix.
You're going to stop smoking.
You might drop dead,
you might,
you know,
explosive diarrhea,
whatever it is.
Like show me.
Yeah.
That's one thing if you're advertising a
car,
right?
You know,
you've got like the newest Cadillac and
it looks cool and you drive and you look
cool.
Driving like,
man,
I want to get one of those.
That's sort of okay,
but if it's another thing,
if it's some crazy you meant,
you remember there was a drug that they
were selling for a while.
They were advertising that was a
supplement to your current
antidepressants.
Oh,
that was like an bill,
a fly or something like that.
Was that the one with the cloud?
The cartoon cloud that was following the
guy?
I think it was because if you have a
cartoon in cloud,
you've got some serious problems,
but there's something fucked up about
advertising for something that's a drug
that can affect your mind and possibly
cause suicidal thoughts because
advertising is entirely designed to coax
you into buying the product.
Sure.
And that's a big life to say.
Ask Your doctor about it and that you
shouldn't be allowed to say that.
You shouldn't be allowed to say it
because then every first off,
everybody's on prescription drugs.
I'm not on any prescription drugs right
now.
I have been for about six months also
around the time I was on Lexapro or one
of those mild kills your Dick to.
You got a double whammy.
It was getting kicked.
Punched.
Well,
he's back.
He's back.
And better than ever.
Yeah,
success.
But I was on one of those and when I,
when I got off,
I know you're supposed to tell your
psychiatrist or whatever because they'll
ween you off it.
But I was like,
I didn't like the guy and I was like,
I'm just going to get off this thing.
He didn't like the psychiatrists are
keeping shit from them.
I didn't like.
His last name was Ruben,
which is why I went to him and then I
just didn't like them and I was like,
fuck this.
I'm not going to do it.
But anyway,
uh,
I just figured,
all right,
I take,
instead of taking one a day,
I'll just do one every other day and
then one every three days,
something like that.
And it worked.
I weaned off if I kid you not,
I swear to God this is true.
I remember when you used to turn on an
old computer,
like an old desktop computer,
all the worrying and the buzzing and
you'd hear the hard drive spinning and
all that shit.
I could feel that in my brain for about
two weeks when I got off it.
Whoa.
I felt my brain actually resetting or
something like literally a worrying
there was like.
And then like little sparks.
Was this when you were thinking or
anytime?
I just remember I lived in New York City
at the time.
I remember very vividly one day I was
walking down in Amsterdam and I was
maybe a week out and I felt my brain
like just coming back on.
So that shit,
it does something to you.
It does something and forget.
And the boner stuff,
and you know,
all that I had of the reason I got off
it actually was because one of my best
friends,
childhood best friends was killed in a
car accident.
And uh,
when I heard I had almost no reaction is
one of my best friends from four years
old and I just was like,
I was sad,
but like I didn't have a sad reaction,
you know,
like I knew it was sad,
but my reaction was and said,
and then I was like,
all right,
that's it.
That's tough.
It's a terrifying thing to remove the
lows.
Yeah.
All the lows.
The lows are there to teach you.
Yeah.
I mean,
you gotta learn,
you gotta learn from failure.
Failure is important.
It's an and,
and,
and feeling bad is important.
It's,
it really is because it makes,
it,
makes you understand and appreciate the
magnitude of feeling good.
I like it.
It draws you towards that as a better
alternative.
Sure.
And especially as an artist that someone
that speaks and is supposed to have a
full set of emotions,
I'd be able to go on stage,
tell people what I think,
you know,
that's the argument with school
shooters.
One of the things about school shooters
is a massively disproportionate amount
of them are on.
And the idea is that they can do that
and you know,
the what is,
for what,
you know,
what came first,
is it the disease,
the mental illness that causes them to
be able to shoot somebody in the first
place?
Or is it the fact that they're on pills?
Is it the fact that they're on pills
because they're mentally ill?
Who the fuck knows?
But people that I know that have been on
various antidepressants,
Ssri is whatever they,
they tell you that things don't bother
them.
The.
So if things don't bond,
like shooting people,
like the lack of empathy.
Like it seems to me in my armchair
psychology,
you know,
position that that would just be a
correlation there.
Well
it's always why we have a real
inability in America to talk about two
things at once.
That two things can be true at the same
time.
So like when you look at the shootings
immediately,
the people who are against guns will say
it's about guns and the people who are
for guns will say it's about mental
health.
Pretty sure two things can be true at
the same time.
Absolutely.
We have a mental health problem and we
have to easy access to guns.
I'm a hunter.
I'm pretty sure your second amendment
right.
Yes.
Yeah.
I'm,
I believe in the second amendment we
should be able to arm ourselves,
but it is still too easy to get guns.
You shouldn't be able to necessarily
have a assault rifle to plow down 30
people.
It was all that.
Um,
but at the same time,
yeah,
a huge percentage of these people are on
some sort of medication.
That's not a coincidence.
Not all men,
if they didn't have something wrong with
them,
no matter how many guns you had access
to your,
your,
uh,
relatively same guy,
no matter how many guns you have,
you're not going to shoot a school,
right?
Yeah.
So that says,
yeah,
there's some mental health component to
this.
Well,
I think it should be really difficult to
get a car to.
I mean I think it should be get
difficult to get a gun.
I mean in,
in so as they should do some sort of
background check.
They should.
They should evaluate whether or not you
have any competency whatsoever.
Have you.
How much have you learned about shooting
a gun?
And that's not the case right now.
I mean the other problem is there's so
many guns out there that the people that
are doing this shit,
like this last guy in Oregon,
I think he didn't get the gun.
It was his mom that got the same
results.
I can get a gun even if even if you
shouldn't be able to get a gun that is
an issue,
but we should make it more difficult.
And the mental health aspect of it as a
huge problem.
And to say that it's not that it's only
a gun issue is,
is a blind thing that people do.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
I think there's,
there's a bunch of different issues at
stake here and I think that's the case
with a lot of different things and
that's one of the problems that I have
with like the idea of a left and a
right.
I think I have a lot of left ideas,
almost all of them,
you know,
and then I'll have a few right ideas I
have.
I'm on sort of both sides of a lot of
shit.
Yeah.
Well I definitely want to get into that
with you because that's become like my,
my home now.
This is really the split on the left
between what I'm calling the regressives
and people that I think really stand for
liberal principles.
That's all on the left.
But yeah,
I have some good.
I have a lot.
Look,
comedians in general I think have hugely
strong libertarian leanings because you
want to be.
I'm a firm believer that the government
should have very little to do with our
lives,
make sure I don't get shot,
which they're not that great at that,
uh,
you know,
take care of the economy,
keep us safe.
Like that pretty much is what I think
the government's role should be.
That's it.
That's about it,
you know,
make sure we have a good education
system.
The road should be okay.
You're like pretty limited stuff.
And I think usually for some reason
comedians do fall on that scale.
You know,
Chris Rock is there a bill Maher,
this,
a zillion comedians on that side of it.
Um,
but I've seen a massive split in the
left right now and this goes to all the
social justice warrior shit and
everyone's a racist and a homophobe and
it's fucking exhausting.
And it's a,
well look,
you've had Sam Harris on a bunch of
times.
Look what these people have done to Sam
Harris.
It's insane.
They're just using him as a target or
that's what I believe.
I believe that instead of looking at his
actual positions and being objective and
saying,
does he have a point?
What is his point?
Let's debate the point.
Let's,
let's debate the merits of the point.
Instead.
He's a guy that you can point to and say
he will.
He has a strong position about Islam,
so he is Islamophobic.
He is there for racist and he should be
attacked and fuck that piece of shit.
And I mean I've seen the same written
about Christopher hitchens.
You know,
I saw some people when he died that were
running good written,
so I made fun of this one social justice
war because he was saying good riddance
to Hitchens,
but then when Osama bin Ladin died,
he was like,
I'm not going to celebrate the death of
any human being like,
well,
this is fucking hilarious.
This is.
Yeah,
I know what you're doing.
You're not thinking.
You're not thinking you're,
you're writing things.
And this is part of the problem with
social media and I think one of the
things that we're finding with this
whole social social justice warrior
issue is that it's not necessarily just
opinions.
It's opinions that are being expressed
in a way where they know people are
going to hear it.
They know people are going to see their
writing and so that that knowledge that
someone's going to see what you're
writing and react to it either positive
or negative effects your choices.
It's like reality TV and what they're
doing is like when you see people act
fake on reality TV because you know that
they know the cameras are on them.
That's what you're doing when you make a
retarded social justice warrior tweet,
you're a hundred percent right.
So I know someone,
I can't get their name,
who right now is pretty big in their
reality space on a reality show right
this second.
No,
the very well.
And he says to me all the time like
that's what he's doing.
All he's doing is ramping up to stay on
the show to keep the whole thing though,
of course.
And that's what these people are doing.
So Sam,
how many times has he been here at least
twice,
right?
Horror,
four or five.
Four or five times.
So you've sat with this guy for hours
and hours with this guy.
Do you think he's racist in any way
whatsoever,
but he's.
You know what he is,
he's fearless.
Yes.
And,
and I'm not saying he doesn't have fear
of normal consequences of,
you know,
whatever danger.
It's not that,
it's just that if he has a principal who
express it and I've,
I've disagreed with them about certain
points,
of course,
his,
his principles and his opinions are,
he will truly express,
express them.
And in unpopular subjects,
like when you're talking about Islam or
you're talking about religion in
general,
I mean,
he takes a tremendous amount of heat
about that and he only gets it for Islam
though,
right?
Because that's the truth of it.
Like this is a guy who wrote a letter to
a Christian nation.
Guess what it was about Christianity.
Nobody called him a Christian.
A phobe,
right?
So when Bill Maher,
so that night then the whole thing all
hell broke loose with athletic on unreal
time or heaven.
Heaven broke loose,
right?
Exactly.
Uh,
whatever you want to call it.
Some imaginary bullshit.
Um,
that night.
And I know we both talked about this at
time,
but what happened was athletic
immediately went to the social justice
warrior.
I'm holier than thou,
I'm going to portray,
protect the downtrodden thing,
right,
and it was nonsense and bullshit.
Sam Sat there.
Again,
you can disagree with the premise of
what he says.
You can disagree with his feelings on
profiling or nuclear first strike,
but he'll debate all of those.
I sat with him for an hour and a half
and he would have done three hours,
but our crew guys had to leave.
I mean,
this is a guy who will stake out these
positions and unpopular positions and
put them out there and they just want to
shout him down and what the.
What the real thing though is it's the
chilling effect on that.
Is that what?
It's not about shutting down,
Sam.
If Sam disappears tomorrow,
I think it would be really bad for our
discourse as a country and I think this
is a guy saying important shit,
but ultimately guess what?
They're going to come for Joe Rogan.
They're going to come for Dave Rubin and
they're going to come for all the other
people that are tweeting about
and what they're really doing is just
trying to take the moral high ground.
They're trying to teach you some more
shit of being like.
First of all,
if,
if Ben Affleck had a real nuanced and
objective position,
he certainly didn't express it on that
show.
You mean racist,
racist.
He's a fucking idiot.
It really is a fucking idiot.
You know?
I don't know that I can go see that
Batman movie because he,
I,
he has turned me.
I love superhero movies.
Love them.
With that.
The
fact that he was willing to take that
position on a show like that and argue
with that without,
without.
I mean,
first of all,
I like Bill Maher.
I think he's a very funny comic that
show socks.
This is.
This is why I like it a lot.
It's like socks.
It's doesn't suck because it's a sucky
show.
It sucks because all these subjects are
massively important and have a bunch of
people shouting over each other.
Like here,
like you and I have very strong opinions
and we want to express ourselves and
there's only two of us luckily because
it was,
if there was five of us in the room
right now and we're all talking,
it would be really hard to fucking get
your points across because you've got to
kind of like jump in and,
and,
and this is what happens when you get a
guy like Sam Harris and a guy like Ben
Affleck and Ben Affleck,
which you're saying you're so racist,
right?
So racist.
Right?
Instead of having an hour to go,
okay,
well why don't you tell me why it's
racist and give me your thoughts in the
Middle East and tell me what you would
do about,
you know,
x amount of people who are so entangled
in their ideology that they want death
upon people.
They wish death upon people who leave
the religion.
Yeah.
Tell me what you would do about that.
Tell me what you do about people that
think that it's wrong to have women go
to school.
Tell me what you would do about.
We're talking about ideologies.
You can call it Islam,
you can call it the moonies,
you can call it,
scientology,
can call it whatever the fuck you want,
but what it really is is a rigid set of
ideologies.
It's these are ideologies that you are
forced to subscribe to a predetermined
pattern of behavior and thinking,
and if you are not in that predetermined
pattern of behavior and thinking they
wished death upon you and they think
that they should be able stone you.
If you're a homosexual,
they should be able to stone you.
If you're an adulterer,
there's a horrible video online of this
poor woman whose father throws the first
rock.
I've seen it.
Have you seen it?
She wants to touch him before,
before he kills her and he,
he won't touch her hand and he hits her
with the rock.
But think about the absurd.
So there's,
there's so much here,
right?
So thinking about the absurdity of this,
that the hatred for these people,
the hatred for Sam,
for Bill Maher.
So whether you like them or not,
when I say it sucks,
what I know is that the constructs,
all those talk show format suck those
splitscreen,
but bill o'reilly things bill talks and
three experts shot.
We'll be right back.
It's just not enough time.
I look,
Bill Maher loves Bernie Sanders.
Obviously he had them on the show last
week.
He only had six minutes with.
That's crazy.
Imagine what year you would do with that
guy.
If he was here right now we could.
We could literally talk all day and he
should and he should and should have a
show like that where it's just bill
sitting down with these people and not
being forced into that fucking
soundbitey type of conversation because
that's what they're doing.
Well listen,
I love bill,
but I'll do that.
You'll have that that day,
so thank you for that and you'll be
fucking let him.
That's fine.
I just think that format is like
everybody thinks that everybody needs to
be like fast,
fast,
fast.
It's not the case.
Well look,
I think both of us are proof that it's
not the kids.
I think for a long time everything was
getting smaller and smaller.
The Internet burst.
This thing twitter came out,
we're going to talk in 140 characters.
Buying came at six seconds,
so everything kept getting smaller,
smaller,
smaller.
But what I'm absolutely seeing now,
we've only been doing my show in its
current incarnation for two months.
Sam was my first guest.
This was the first week in September and
we started doing long form stuff again,
exactly what you're doing here.
And what I've seen is the more,
the longer we go,
the more we extrapolate ideas,
talk about stuff and don't scream at
each other.
I'm bringing on people on the right and
on the left and the more that we do
this,
the more people want.
So I think there's a bounce back now
from that short thing,
you know,
where everybody on television,
they start,
you know,
and it's partly like a show that I love
on espn.
Pardon the interruption.
And they would have the countdown going,
you know,
and everything had to be quick,
quick,
quick.
But I think people are actually ready
for this.
And,
and I think clearly,
and I don't think it,
I mean that's why this is working for
you.
You know what I mean?
People want to actually hear a couple of
thoughts.
Let's hear two things that don't
necessarily line up and let's hear
people that I listen.
I hope that plenty of people that will
be listening to this will disagree with
me,
will disagree with you.
And at the end we'll go,
well it's not because they're racist,
but they got some ideas that let's
challenge those ideas.
Well I think the entertainment aspect of
those shows where there's like five
people in a room and then also you have
a fucking audience that cheers and they
agree and some and some of them are just
so lefty,
so super fucking applauding and every.
Because he shuts up his own audience,
which,
how many Qa?
I've literally seen him do standup where
he's yelled at the audience for giving
him applause breaks.
I mean,
how many times have you ever seen that
in a comedy show?
That that's pretty good.
We,
yeah,
in,
during his show,
he does do that with people chime in,
but I just think that the entertainment
aspect of,
of expressing yourself almost sometimes
takes precedent over the concepts and
the ideas themselves because it's all in
how you deliver it and how forcefully
you can get it past the other people
that are trying to say contrary points.
So the Ben Affleck thing is the perfect
example of that because by yelling out
gross and racist within a minute.
Right.
So think about it.
It's pretty much the worst thing you can
say about somebody right to call them
racist.
That's pretty,
you know,
beyond you're a child molester or
something.
It's pretty much the worst thing you can
say.
Think about if you were having an
argument with somebody about,
about this stuff,
let's say you were privately arguing
with someone about Islam and religion
and blah blah,
blah.
It would take a while for you to call
them racist,
right?
Like you wouldn't do it to go pretty
deep by the time that you personally got
there,
to that place where you were to say you
are racist.
I don't think I would even,
I would probably say that idea is
racist.
Right?
So that would even say your racist
because I got to think that like some
people will say,
wow,
I have black friends.
Well what do you like about black
people?
You know,
like you go into that for and at the end
of it,
well they smell different.
I like to be around people that are done
with me.
Okay.
You're a fucking racist.
You're a racist.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like,
but,
but that illustrates your point
perfectly that the problem with these
shows and the problem with this
discussion and problem with social
justice,
it's all like a perfect storm of
craziness because the next day after
that show,
all the online sites mediate everybody.
The headlines were all Ben Affleck Calls
Bill Maher and Sam Harris Racist.
So suddenly the onus was on them to
prove that they are not raised exactly.
That is not only is that bonkers,
but I asked them about this and he,
he said something that I thought was
fascinating.
He was on that show to discuss his book
called Waking Up,
which is a spiritual guide to a guide to
spirituality without religion.
So he's talking about meditation.
He's talking about inner peace.
I've read the book,
you know,
like some pretty lofty stuff.
He said,
from that point forward,
the next six months in my life,
we're on a book tour about inner peace,
but all I had to do is defend myself
that I'm not a racist.
How cosmically war that is.
Well,
and it came from,
I believe Ben Affleck wanting to state a
position that he felt would be very
popular and when resonate it would get
him social brownie points because that's
what he did.
What he said,
the way they express themselves.
It's not nuanced.
It's not objective is not complex and
well thought out and it's a very,
very deep and important subject and
massively important subject because what
we're talking about in 2015 when you
talking about any ancient religion,
you're talking about clinging to these
ideas that were formed and ingrained in
these communities well before science.
Well before people had a deep
understanding of human psychology.
Of human nature of the power of
suggestion and culture and well before
we understood the the world actually
works as far as like as far as nature,
as far as physics,
as far as just the formation of the
universe.
All of this information is not
applicable to most of the religions in
the world today.
Not only are you right,
but that's even what Sam wrote in and
the faith that fat fucking Batman before
the movie even came out,
the new Batman like think how insane
that is.
If you really step back and dissect what
you just said there,
that if you took what the average person
thought over the world and of science
and medicine and everything that we know
of and food and everything in 1840 by
that standard now in 2015,
that person would look pretty damn dumb,
but for some reason these books that
were written thousands of years in
whatever it is,
somehow those have some validity that we
should still respect.
We shouldn't respect these books.
They're ideas.
They're ideas that time has long since
let go of.
So by respecting them,
we're actually doing something crazy.
If we want,
if we really want to be free,
if we want to be free thinkers and
people that I don't give a fuck about
anyone's race or religion or sex or
sexuality,
I judge people on what they say and what
they think and what the social justice
warriors are doing.
They're trying to win this argument by
shutting everybody down.
Yes,
and they they're doing it.
I think there is a degree of them doing
it for lofty reasons.
I think Ben Affleck thinks in his lofty,
rich Hollywood,
whatever,
that he's helping the downtrodden.
I think there's something he does really
know entirely circle.
You know why?
Because I know too many actors and I
know what they are and you know,
here's.
Here's the thing about actors,
and this is not all actors,
obviously just like,
you know,
not all comics are heroin addicts and
drug addicts and whatever.
I think that what it is to be an actor
is to pretend to be something else.
Right?
That's,
that's what it is and it's also you have
to get passed the audition process and
the audition process is essentially
saying all the right things.
So Dave,
wherever you're from,
where'd you grow up?
And you have to like,
you know who you voted for this.
Like there's,
there's that shit.
There's a reason why Hollywood liens
almost entirely left.
Right.
Do you think they really do,
because I think a lot of them are
secretly voting Republican taxes.
Right?
You know,
you've got your Charleston Heston's in
your fucking,
you know,
there's,
there's a few John voight's out there
and the guy from the was,
it will be back in two and two with a
chuckle or chuck will follow him on
twitter just to laugh at all the fucking
Republican Shit that he writes.
There's,
there's always gonna be a few Hollywood
conservatives.
Obviously Chuck woolery is not in any
big movies like that,
but there always going to be a few
conservatives in Hollywood.
The casting people,
the PR,
the producers,
the executives overwhelmingly left
leaning and to be in that club you have
to agree with them and there's a problem
with that whole audition process when it
comes to actors.
You can't work unless someone approves
you,
unless someone takes you in and accepts
you and chooses you.
Dave,
you're the right guy for the part.
Yes.
Yeah.
Now you're.
And you can't say anything controversial
that will fuck that up.
And then you're essentially like,
you're on a dating program for the
world.
Not,
not dating,
like you're trying to get laid,
but like you're trying to get the world
to love you.
Yeah.
So when a guy like Ben Affleck who's
been doing this,
his whole life gets on that show and
someone says something that he thinks I
can get in here and make some fucking
points.
I can get some social brownie points up
on the board.
I think that's racist.
You're racist and this is gross.
He's just like a guy at an audition.
He's full of Shit.
You know what Rogan I'm going to prove
to you right now that I,
uh,
I don't just say shit,
but I believe it because you've changed
my mind.
That argument was good enough that
you've changed my mind that I do agree
that he wasn't doing it out of some
lofty thing that it's purely that I'm
with I,
there might be a,
you know,
maybe we can split hairs a little bit
and it's 80 slash 20 or whatever,
but I think that actually does make more
sense and it also explains why it
happened within a minute because he was
ready for it to happen before the
segment even started.
So yeah,
I'll go.
I think there are also sociopath to get
involved in philanthropic ventures to
make themselves look good.
Oh sure.
I absolutely 100 percent believe that
some people do some philanthropic shit
so that it makes them look better.
And,
and,
and this is,
this is sort of to mask the psychosis
that bubbles below the surface of their
skin that they're trying to hide from
people.
Like you can't go after me.
I work with the firefighters,
you know,
I'm,
I support the first responders
responders,
you know,
I'm down with the firefighters.
You can't call me a plagiarist,
but you can like send Dusky,
like we'll,
we'll be working with little kids
helping all these little kids won't
securely.
That guy's not fucking them.
How could he do that?
He loves the children.
I mean that,
that is the kind of shit that happens
with a lot evil
people.
So this is interesting.
So for comics then it really is
particularly bizarre because there's the
approval thing,
right?
And comics want approval just the same
way actors,
but comics are also the good ones and
unfortunately there's not many of us
left that you're supposed to stake out
controversial positions.
So that goes against the sort of mass
approval thing,
but it doesn't in comedy but.
But right now he's counterculture.
Cool.
Right now.
Does,
does any.
Is there any comic.
There's a couple people I guess,
that are doing some counterculture
stuff.
Okay.
Letter.
Getting credit for find counterculture.
What counterculture that you'd be?
You'd be really against the government.
You'd be against the administration,
you know,
you'd be fighting more for some of the
things that I think we're doing with the
social justice where yourself fighting
for free speech,
relentlessly fighting against bad ideas
so you could be fighting against the
ideas of Islam without being racist or
you're going to race,
but without even being,
without being bigoted towards Muslim
people.
Like right now I think partially because
of Obama,
it's cool to like the president,
you know what I mean?
Just by his,
by the.
He's black,
he's cool.
I'd love to play basketball with him.
I'm sure he'd be fun to have a drink
with.
So it's cool to like the power right
now.
So in a weird way,
I think if we have a republican
president next time comedy's going to
get a lot better real quick because it's
going to be a lot easier to
attack.
But is it cool to like him?
If you look at the facts is a cool to
like when you look at the ways attacked,
whistleblowers is like nobody's talking
about that.
That's my point.
People are,
there's plenty of people are they are in
podcasts.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know a lot of really smart people that
are attacking it.
All right,
well that guy's truck trussell,
Duncan trussell Kurt Metzger.
I know a lot of like very smart comics
that just think it's fucking gross that
you've got a guy that's killed more
innocent people with drones or been
responsible for being the lead.
The commander and chief of the greatest
army in the world has ever known that
has caused thousands of people to die
innocently through drone strikes.
You know that like they're shooting it
cell phones,
they're shooting missiles at where a
cell phone is and that's what,
that's what metadata is.
We just blew up that hospital,
blew up that hospital and you know,
we could get into a whole thing about
the,
about the Middle East,
but like there,
there's terrible shit or the
whistleblower thing I think is a good
spot because you hear Edward Snowden on
um,
uh,
Neil degrasse Tyson's show.
No,
I didn't.
You should listen to it.
It's amazing.
It's great,
but please go look,
that's what Obama is doing right now.
That's what he's doing.
There's a reason that Obama,
you know,
a lot of people on the left,
the progressives,
when Obama got in immediately we're
like,
you know,
he has to try,
Cheney for war crimes and Blah Blah
Blah.
And there's a reason why he didn't.
That wasn't just about power.
It was also because he's killing a lot
of people with drones right now.
In 20 years from now,
he doesn't want that president,
President Willow Smith or whoever it's
going to be to come in.
And Samantha,
like j dot j.
that's pink isn't going to win.
Probably.
Maybe.
I guess Jayden probably would be the
president and curse there.
I don't know,
but like whoever is going to be,
it's going to be one of them.
I might vote for will.
How about that?
You'd vote for.
Well,
I had my vote for will smith.
Is he running?
I don't know,
but he's a smart motherfucker and I
like,
I like when I listened to him talk,
I think he's a balanced and intelligent
guard that expresses himself very well.
He's extremely well read,
but it's not a scientologist A.
I don't think he's a scientologist,
but I think he's dabbled.
So as Jerry Seinfeld,
they look.
I bought dianetics.
I bought it on an online,
not even online.
I got it from one of those late night
infomercials in 1994 when I first moved
to Hollywood.
I remember those commercials all the
time in the middle of the night for me
while I'm in the middle of Lawrence
Wright's going clear hallways.
I can read it for too long,
man.
I go to other books because I read it
for like a few chapters and I go,
fuck this because it's so crazy.
The thing on Hbs,
I started the book first,
then I watched the thing on hbo and then
I keep going back to the book,
but I haven't finished.
It's got.
It's got like probably I'm probably
halfway in,
but I,
I,
I can't,
you know,
it's weird about Kendall's.
You don't see that you're halfway in.
You see numbers like I like,
I like a thickness thing where I'm like,
I'm down to the bottom.
I got like a very thin.
But even the numbers on that doesn't
mean anything to me.
Those numbers at the bottom,
that show,
you know,
you're on page 100 and 500 pages.
That's not,
it's not registering.
How do you,
how do you decide if someone in this
space,
how much information to put in your
brain?
Because that's one of the things that I
choose.
Problem.
Yeah.
I struggle with this all the time
because I love politics and I,
I told you I've been going to the spin
rooms.
We can talk about some politics stuff.
Um,
and I love all that stuff and I love
current events and I love Middle East
politics and I love talking about
religion,
all of this shit.
Like I love all that.
That's what I'm here for,
right?
I'm on this earth,
that's what I'm here for.
But I do find sometimes I can't.
There's just too much coming into my
brain.
And then when you have my,
you know,
sitting on the couch and I'm watching
Seinfeld,
which I should be,
should be the time that I can shut my
brain down,
write an episode that I've seen 150
times before that I know every line
coming out and I had my ipad and I have
my iphone and my laptop there and I'm
doing this and it's like,
it's like minority report from health
and I really struggled with that,
like shutting it down sometimes and you
know,
I'm not even just talking about the
devices but just actually the stuff
putting in your brain all the time and
you gotTa Know Your Shit,
you know,
it's tough.
Well,
fortunately I don't necessarily really
have to know my shit because you know,
your shit I'll have to do is say I'm not
sure about that and I'm okay because I'm
a comedian,
right?
We don't.
But you know what I mean,
like especially in these sorts of
conversations like you and I,
we exchanged some emails about some
stuff that'd be cool to talk about,
but we don't have a format.
Obviously we're all over the place where
gay discos and Ben Affleck's Douche and
Bill Maher's formats are antiquated and
there's,
you can only have so much information in
your head and this is part of the
problem that I have with is going clear
book.
Why keep going to it and then going to
other shit.
It's because I feel like,
why am I fucking reading so much about
this sociopath fucking nightmare,
crazy cult leader dude,
that,
that has formed this insane religion
because I can't.
Part of me can't put it down.
Pardon me?
I started reading about all the crazy
shit that he did and how nutty this guy
really was and how many people followed
his wacky ideas.
That becomes fascinating.
Could be talking about scientology or
any religion.
I could some wacky guy with some crazy
ideas.
That's a thought.
Somebody was talking to him.
Next thing you know.
Yeah.
Well there wasn't a lot of cash.
Well,
there's,
you know,
obviously there's different ones and
some of them,
the followers,
like Mormons are notoriously nice
people.
I could tell that was one of the
weirdest religions because there so
nice.
But then like if you go to Islam,
Mohammed was a warlord.
Yeah.
And it's got a very different type of
religion when first of all,
you're dealing with the environment that
these people live in is extremely
hostile as far as the temperature is
extremely hot.
The,
the,
the battle for natural resources is very
difficult.
Is the end.
You're also dealing with the cradle of
civilization and I have this bit about
Islam that it never really came to
fruition,
but the eye,
not even Islam but the Middle East
rather.
But the Middle East is essentially like
they're the townies of the world because
that's where culture was created and
everybody looked.
Human beings were created in Africa.
That's where the first human beings came
from out by however method,
whether you believe in heaven,
illusion and the drop some shit.
A promethium fucking terrible to be
good.
I wanted it to be good.
I watched the beginning again,
you know,
with the,
with the guy and he comes down and he
splits the thing and I was like,
what?
What?
What happened here?
The idea is that he ceded the world with
his DNA and then he knew somehow or
another would develop and the human
being.
Why did shortlist ron not move a little
to the left when the thing was falling?
Remember the end.
Oh yeah.
There's the giant ship and it's falling
and all she has to do,
she's running straight in the ships ball
in this way and it's slow.
Real slow.
I want you to do is go a little panic
attack.
She just freaked out.
She freaked out or panicked.
I don't know this.
We can get into that all day.
She made up for it in a Mad Max.
Yeah.
That was awesome.
Um,
what was my point?
What the fuck
we're going took you somewhere there.
The beginning of the world.
Mesopotamia
came from this one.
The,
the,
the most ancient version of a human
being like,
I think they think that we're in this
current form,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think they're thinking it's like
250,000
plus years,
right?
So whatever that was at one point in
time,
they left Africa and a lot of them
settled in the Middle East.
Egypt of course is a part of Africa,
but it is in the Middle East officially,
and they spread out all throughout the
country.
But the,
the oldest,
what we know today as far as we know,
the oldest written language,
the oldest,
uh,
agriculture,
the oldest government structure was
Sumir.
And that's where Iraq is,
you know,
is you're dealing with like 6,000
plus years ago.
That's,
that's Iraq.
I mean,
that is,
that,
that's the cradle of civilization.
It's a fucking shit hole,
a crazy wacky,
fucked up civil war.
The Muslims are fighting,
the Muslims that she has and the
Sudanese are blowing each other up on
roadside bombs.
And it's chaos.
It's chaos.
And when you get to these parts of the
world that are amongst the most ancient
cultures,
you have what I call the echoes of
savages is like the culture has lasted
for so long and the reverberations of
these ancient ideas that have been long
disproven and they're still there,
they're there,
permeated.
Look,
that's why the Middle East especially,
we could also talk about Israel,
Palestinian people and all of it is such
a cluster fuck because so you could take
someone like Sam who will talk about it
from the religious part,
right,
and he'll mostly blame religion and then
you can take a lot of my friends on the
left and they say it's all geopolitics
and they usually blame the United
States.
The truth is,
and as I said before,
we have to have two thoughts at once and
I know it's very hard for people to be
able to do that.
It's both.
It is both in the most extreme ways.
Look,
first of Iraq and Syria right now are
not even countries.
Your by any estimation of what a
functioning country is that would
partake in the world thing,
nor is Libya.
Libya is not in.
Look,
we did think about Libya for second.
Obama did that.
No Congressional authorization,
right?
Everyone goes crazy on Bush about Iraq.
Now obviously in retrospect,
the Iraq war is pretty bad and you can
clearly make a line to it led to Isis,
which then has now dba destabilize the
whole thing,
but he at least had congressional
authorization.
Now maybe he lied where we know now know
that they were planting evidence and all
that,
but Obama went into Libya right when he
became president with no congressional
authorization.
I have no idea what's going on in Libya
right now.
Is it a,
is it a country?
Have you seen a board Danes show on it?
The CNN show?
Uh,
I don't think it has.
There been a Libyan just watching it
last night about a Ethiopia that shows
amazing.
Yeah,
he's,
he's amazing.
But you know,
it's,
it was,
it was shit when Kadafi was running it,
obviously it was a horrible,
horrible place and he was a terrible
evil dictator.
But when you remove a dictator,
you create a vacuum and that vacuum gets
sucked up by people that want to try to
claim power.
Well,
this is,
this is the strange thing about the
neocons,
right?
So neo-cons believed that we should use
our American power to either nation
build or you know,
like I know,
and everyone on the left,
they'll say,
well,
they're doing it because we want their
natural resources.
Like it's again,
it's one of these things that there's a
zillion reasons why everyone wants some
piece of that part of the world,
but people will say,
well,
Iraq was better off with Saddam.
He was doing horrible things to his
people.
He was using mustard gas on the,
on the courage,
right.
I think it was the Kurds.
Um,
so we've,
we've helped.
We backed leaders.
Mubarak in Egypt was our guy.
We backed him.
Then they overthrew him.
Then we backed the Muslim Brotherhood
than they overthrew them.
Now we're backing another Mubarak I
like,
we just do.
Our policies are all crazy.
It's all military industrial complex and
it's just this endless cycle of
craziness over there.
I mean,
you can't get any crazier than having a
guy like Dick Cheney as the vice
president who the CEO of Halliburton
accompany the rebuilds places that we
blow up.
It sounds like a shorts and egor movie,
right?
Like he's the bad guy in shorts and
acrimony from the eighties or the bad
guy in Rambo.
I mean it's,
it's almost so obvious and that's why we
can't believe it.
You know,
it ain't because they're showing it to
us.
Exactly.
Here's what it is,
guys.
No big deal.
Halliburton,
by the way,
they're doing a lot of shit in Iraq
right now.
You think it's coincidence?
Not only that,
they got no bid contracts.
Nobody has to bed.
They have other people who are
competing.
What do we do?
What do we,
what do we do?
We hope that inflammation and the
distribution of information that's
available today that was barely
available when Bush was in office and we
hope that the spread of that and the
understanding of that will balance out
all this shit and I'm hoping that that's
the case with social justice warriors.
I'm hoping that's the case with these
right wing
fucking fanatics that want to blow up
and bomb and invade everything that
doesn't believe in Jesus.
I'm hoping that all that stuff gets
balanced out because I think the amount
of change that we've experienced in our
lifetime is unprecedented cultural
change information will change,
has been the big one.
The,
the,
the invention of the Internet.
I forget.
I fully believe that when we go back and
historians look at this point in time,
they,
they see it as an explosion of change,
like a veritable explosion of ideas and
have the ability to express themselves
and your show represents that your,
your podcast represents that you don't
have anybody telling you what to do.
You can talk about whatever you want.
There's no,
there's no studio execs come in and go,
stop Dave.
We've got to get off this subject.
Dave,
you can't talk about Ben Affleck.
We're doing a film with Ben.
One of our subsidiaries is very upset
with this and that and that.
You know,
the affiliates are calling in right now.
They want to cancel our program.
We're gonna have to figure out a way to
do this better.
You said some bad things about abilify.
Abilify is one of our new sponsors and
you should ask your doctor about it
because maybe you need it.
Yeah.
Then my cloud gets even bigger.
That's hanging over me all the time.
It's really important,
but yeah.
I'm with you,
but do you think we've gotten to a
breaking point with that because I think
one of the.
One of the reasons that I wanted to do
this with you and I've been harassing
you to come on my show forever is
because I see the things that we're
talking about and our audiences are so
interlaced.
Right?
And I really,
really believe it has a lot to do with
the Sam thing,
but I think there's been.
We're close to the tipping point of
defeating the Social Justice Warriors.
I really think themselves right?
Well,
because because identity politics
ultimately has to eat itself.
That's the fatal flaw,
so that they'll take someone like Bernie
Sanders who stands for every fucking
progressive principle known to man.
He doesn't want money in politics.
He's everything that the left wants and
what happens?
He has black lives matter.
People grabbing the mic away from him a
month ago screaming.
He doesn't care enough about black lives
when,
when there's no reason to believe that,
but if but if you parse everyone down to
their one issue,
so if you say that these people are only
going to care about black lives matter
and these people are only going to care
about abortion and these people are only
going to care about Islam or whatever it
is,
you ultimately your goal,
you're just a group of people who
ultimately have interests that have
nothing to do with each other and you're
going to destroy each other and that's
why I think the reaction to this is so
good and so powerful and I think it's.
It's real.
It's happening right now.
I could feel it.
Well when that black lives matter thing
happened,
those girls were screaming and then he
was saying,
we're going to give them the mic from
afterwards.
Like what?
That is not how you get to express
yourself.
That's not how you do it.
You don't interrupt and decide that your
message is more important than their
mess.
Yeah,
and of course their format,
their place with their microphone at the
same time.
What did they probably end up doing?
I don't have any empirical evidence on
this,
but they probably ended up strengthening
the people that don't like them.
You see what this,
what this is doing,
you know,
so there,
there's so much to it,
but that's why I really,
I the social justice
warrior thing and it has a lot the Sam
thing in the way that they treated him.
I'm talking about,
you know,
Glenn Greenwald and Reza and my former
boss Janko.
I know you've had on here the way these
people treated him in this dishonest
attack on ideas that it came from the
left.
We're supposed to debate ideas,
right?
We're on the left.
So what are,
what is liberalism stand for?
We believe in the debate of ideas.
You can say the people on the right.
Well they're more dogmatic,
they're more religious.
They don't want to debate ideas.
So I can't deal with those people.
The right went off the deep end a long
time ago,
but I have to care about as someone
that's on the left and that believes in
liberal principles and doesn't want to
see days thrown off the roof in Syria
and all of that shit doesn't mean I want
to invade Syria.
Doesn't mean you don't want to nation
build,
but I should be able to talk about that
without being called a racist or
whatever it is.
And,
and I think we've.
We've hit something here.
I think one of the things that we've hit
is there are people that are balanced
and that are socially aware and that are
fun and interesting to talk to and then
there's social retards and social
retards that form on the left.
They tend to be unbelievably aggressive
and douchey about really good ideas.
Yeah,
like whether it's black lives matter or
whether it's supporting gay rights or
whether it's transgender rights or any
of the ideas that I'm sure you and I
could both agree with what they're doing
and the way they're doing it,
as they found something that gives them
the green light to be an asshole and one
of the things they're doing in being an
asshole is they're making up for being
picked on.
They're making up for being rejected.
They're making up for the abuse that
they've suffered at other people's hands
that have caused them to have this
unbalanced social persona.
And that's what it's all about.
It's about social retards with really
good points.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
you're on it.
So you could use the gay rights thing as
a great example of that.
So,
you know,
look,
we didn't have gay marriage until
officially it was June 26,
happened to be my birthday.
Congratulations on my,
on my birthday.
The Supreme Court said you're asking,
you know,
I was engaged already at the time,
but I kinda liked the idea of getting
gay married when it wasn't fully legal
because then I thought I'd be like
running from the law or something like
that.
Had some.
Yeah,
I was going to be hunting a guy with one
arm,
you know,
who killed my wife.
None of it made sense,
but I had this idea of something in my
head.
But anyway,
if you take that,
that movement,
look,
it happened pretty damn quick.
I know gay people have wanted rights for
a long time,
but if you take the last five years,
the way this thing has evolved and now
it's cool.
Look,
you're,
you're a straight white man.
Pretty much the worst thing there is,
right?
I mean,
that's,
that's what I hear.
Yeah,
you're just awful.
Even sitting here,
terrible person.
It's been,
you know,
very grating for me.
But uh,
if you look at the gay rights thing,
the left was all about it and I ended.
They love games,
they love gays,
they love gays.
But at the end of the day,
now gays have equal rights and I know
there's still job issues and there's
some stuff,
but we got that fucking lady in Kentucky
that.
Yeah.
Oh we can.
Right.
So there's still all kinds of shit.
I don't mean to say that everything's
perfect.
Resistance for the point is the Supreme
Court,
the law of the land now is equal in
terms of marriage.
But what I realized sort of halfway
through that was it's not that the left
really cares about gays as much as sort
of this idea sort of of what you're
talking about.
Because at the end of the day,
now that gay people have equality,
well guess what?
Suddenly gay people might start voting
Republican because they might monitor,
vote on taxes.
They might,
they might,
you know.
So the identity politics thing is only
good for a little while.
And then once everyone's equal,
it's,
it's just,
it's just a way of pitting people
against each other.
Yeah.
Then you really just become a fat person
with pink hair.
Yeah.
That's all you are.
You're not this amazing person with this
moral high ground that stands above and
gets to proclaim how they've been
fighting for rights and screaming and
yelling,
crying.
You're screaming and yelling and crying
because you're socially retarded because
why are these people,
by the way,
why are they all anonymous if there so
lofty in there?
No,
no.
I mean,
I know there's public ones,
but I'm not talking about that,
but I mean the people that'll be yelling
at me over some social justice yet.
What are some.
The writers were so.
Oh yeah,
but that's what I mean.
I'm not defending.
I think people sort of think that
somehow I'm defending the right.
There is nothing.
I agree with these people on.
You know what I mean?
I have to clean my house and my house is
on the left,
so I want the left to be better.
I fully believe now that the
regressives,
which is what the progressives have
become because their ideas are now
regressive,
not progressive,
that they are the tea party of the left
and if the Republicans,
if the average conservative,
whether you agree with them or not.
Five years ago when the tea party was
gaining strength and we're not going to
negotiate with anyone in government shut
downs and all that,
if the average conservative had said,
these are our principles,
whether you agree or not,
we believe in limited government,
all of that stuff,
low taxes,
whatever strong defense,
if they would have said that they might
have been able to reel the tea party and
a little bit,
but instead they just went to their
worst,
the worst piece of them and I see it
happening with us on the left and that's
why I'm so against the regressive left.
We got to bring them back because
otherwise we're going to have the
regressive left and we're gonna have the
tea party and guess what?
The GIG is up.
Yeah,
I,
I agree,
but I think that is what you find in the
universe.
You find this extremely broad range.
You find a spectrum and that spectrum
you have completely psychotic on one
side and completely psychotic horseshoe
thing.
Right?
And then at the end they're the same.
Yeah.
And then this,
it really is.
I mean,
and then there's,
there's a balance and I think that a lot
of,
I think a lot of us given different
circumstances could be swayed to have
different points of view and different
ideas and I,
I'm also polled,
not in a sense like logically,
but I find myself compelled when I see
people that are really religious.
When I listened to like some Muslim guy
that's speaking with great confidence
and the power of Islam and the truth of
Islam,
I find myself compelled.
I don't believe it.
I don't,
I don't support it as an ideology,
but I'm fascinating by the natural
compulsion to want to join that.
The natural human.
Like there's something about someone who
is unbelievably confident in what
they're doing is the right thing and is,
is proclaiming it publicly and loudly
through a microphone that makes you go,
wow,
maybe he's right.
Islam is the truth.
And kinda like hit like exactly like
his.
But that's.
But that's why it's a human nature
thing.
It is human nature.
And look if,
if that's why they attract all these
people,
there's no doubt that that's what's
going on here.
And what we have to do,
listen,
I don't know what's going on in the
universe in the scheme of I have no
freaking idea,
but that doesn't,
that's fertile ground for someone having
to make that leap of faith and being
like,
I don't have any idea.
So yeah,
just say I'm going to follow the Ten
Commandments.
I mean I'm pretty much.
Well I don't believe in religion in any
way whatsoever,
but I get.
If we were to have the 10 commandments,
I'm probably sure I'm pretty much
following them because they're just
basic.
I don't kill people.
I don't covet your neighbor's wife.
That's a gay thing.
But you know,
like there was actually a property
thing,
you know,
it was his property.
You by covenant taking her.
Yeah.
But,
but I mean the point is that you can
live your life as I think both of us do
and probably most of your listeners do
buy.
You can have a set of principles that
has nothing to do with religion and
which is what waking up is about.
Yeah,
that's exactly what we're about.
And that's,
that's the crazy part of what the left
is doing here,
you know,
there's this onslaught against new
atheist,
so against Sam and Richard Dawkins and
uh,
and hitchins even though he's not around
anymore.
And I didn't know what new atheists were
even.
So I started asking some people in,
my friend Kyle said,
he said,
I think it's just an atheist who's
finally saying I'm here because for a
long time atheist wouldn't even say that
they were here.
And now you have the far left is the
ones that are attacking atheist.
Isn't it supposed to be the far right
attacking the people who don't want
anything to do with religion?
It's incredibly warm.
Yeah.
It is incredibly warm ups and it doesn't
make any sense whatsoever.
And there was a real really recent,
um,
have you seen Sam Harris's,
uh,
there's something I tweeted a few days
ago,
Sam Harris on.
It's on something called secular talk.
It's on youtube.
Yeah.
So Kyle is the guy that I just,
uh,
he's the friend that said to me about
the new atheist thing.
So they picked up basically where our
conversation ended because when I did
that and that.
You're gonna play clip.
No,
no,
I'm not.
But I was going to say that Sam snapped.
He snapped.
I wouldn't say snap,
but by his Breton.
Yeah.
He said snapped.
That's how he described it too.
But he expressed himself about what's
really going on with these people,
whether it's Greenwald or I'll let him
pick who it was and what it was.
But if you listen to it,
it's the thing,
the,
the channel on Youtube called secular
talk and the title of it is Sam Harris
on progressivism torture,
religion and foreign policy.
It's fucking fantastic because he's so
elegant,
so eloquent,
elegant as well,
but eloquent.
And he just nails perfectly
expressed what's going on.
So is that the inherent problem then?
Because what I see when I did my sit
down with him,
I laid it out very clearly.
I said to him,
Sam,
let's take the five things that people
misquote you about the most and let's
make it very youtube friendly so that
when these crazy people are screaming
about you,
anyone on twitter can be like,
here's a link.
Give it five minutes.
So we did it and he laid out a,
you know,
the profiling.
He laid out the nuclear first strike.
He laid out all Muslims,
verse Islam,
you know,
all that.
Islam is the mother lode of bad ideas,
which he did backtrack a little bit
because again,
it's about,
it's about ideas,
not the slanders.
Right?
So that's how we laid it out.
And then we.
And then we did the whole thing and I
felt when I was done with that,
sit down again,
this was my first episode of my show.
I was like,
I'm done with this topic.
I,
I felt I had added a little something to
this.
I had helped the discourse a little bit
and then suddenly right after that,
they all were worse.
I'll have Glenn Reza Jank.
They all double down.
Literally.
Glen retweeted a misquote from our
interview that that Sam said it was
something about Sam mentions profiling
and he's talking about Jerry Seinfeld.
He's talking about Jerry Seinfeld,
the comedian Jerry Seinfeld should not
be profiled that this is a guy who
should be able to walk right through
because it's a silly use of resources to
Glen retweet something where they said
people who look like Jerry Seinfeld
completely not what he said.
Well,
first of all,
Jerry Seinfeld easily could be Arab,
so that's I think one of his parents,
his Syrian.
Actually,
that's a ridiculous thing to say,
so not look like him.
By the way,
when Sam does the profiling and he talks
about how he should be profiled based on
his own looks because because he's a.
he's a middle aged man and if a middle,
a middle aged white guy,
whatever.
He's not even talking about the race in
this instance that if me or you,
if me and you,
we're right now going lax that we should
be profiled.
They should look at two guys of a
certain age and whatever,
whatever their criteria are.
Not based on race or religion,
but there should be some more,
uh,
they should look at us in a more curious
way than perhaps an eight year old Dutch
woman that's in a wheelchair or he's
trying to have smart profiling or what
he calls anti profiling.
The problem with profile really is
you're getting profiled by people that
are so fucking dumb.
They work for the TSA.
Right?
So that's,
that's a real issue.
As I read this whole thing that they
give people,
like recognizing facial expressions,
like,
get the fuck outta here.
Have you ever.
You ever like paused for a minute when
you're looking for something and been a
fly on the wall while the TSA agents are
talking to each other about what they
want to eat or what this is saying.
Any and barely paying any attention.
They're just folks work in a job,
you know,
that's what they are.
The folks that got a job.
Well,
to that point,
I mean,
look,
if we really wanted to profile in the
way that profiling should be done,
then you have to do it the way the
Israelis do it,
which is that you're,
they have cameras on everybody watching
every bit of body language and every bit
of nuance.
I mean even I went,
uh,
I went
to Israel I think in 97 and I to get in,
had to go in a separate room and they
asked me every question you could
possibly think of.
I'm a Jew from long island.
I was profiled,
you know what I mean?
Like that.
They're not doing it out of fun.
They're not,
they just don't want their planes to
explode.
And I had to explain something about
where my bar Mitzvah was.
I mean really crazy shit,
but I'm pretty sure they would prefer
not to have to do that.
And I didn't walk away going,
Oh man,
profiling like that.
That's the worst thing that world.
There are certain things that are these.
This is a very difficult discussion to
have because the social justice warriors
make it so that even when we're talking
about this now,
there's this feeling that somehow I'm
before profiling,
I mean,
I think they should just be ignored.
These so called social justice warriors,
and I think that as times going on,
they're becoming so ridiculous that
they're either doing it to themselves.
There was a great story that I tweeted a
couple of days ago,
um,
antifeminist speaker disinvited to
uncomfortable learning in quotes,
lecture series a because she made
students uncomfortable but don't safe
spaces.
But listen to this man.
The thing is called uncomfortable
learning.
That is this the lecture series.
And they disinvited her because she made
students uncomfortable.
I mean,
this is fucking madness.
this is exactly what we're talking about
here.
Also,
think how dangerous it is to do this to
college kid more than anything else.
Because first off,
you're dragging the kids,
right?
We know,
we know that they're all on Ritalin and
all that shit right there on all that.
Now they go to college.
Even the ones that aren't on that,
you if they go to college,
college is supposed to be where you
figure out what your sort of base ideas
are before you go out into the real
world.
If you're going to sign,
you know,
the college is Brandeis University
silenced Ayaan Hirsi Ali.
I have heard on my show next week like I
want to go into that.
Like what?
Insanity.
You know what I mean?
It's perverse at the highest.
What is their dispute?
Because I think the argument was that
she doesn't like Islam,
but she was raised in.
It almost killed her coworker van Gogh's
grandson or whatever was killed on the
street in Holland for cartoon and she's
talking about ideas again and this is
what Sam says all time.
We have to talk about ideas,
not people.
What other set of ideas would we be
afraid to talk about?
What is going on in universities though?
Is it the students that are dictating
the policy by,
by protesting and is it the professors?
I think.
I think it's coming from the professors
partly for what you said before about
athletic,
like there's this idea if you want to be
a professor,
sort of in Gad said talks about this a
lot because he is a college professor
and I know he's had his struggles as
someone that is outing this bullshit.
I think he's had his professional
struggles.
I think in our interview he talked a
little bit about some exchanges he's had
with other professors where they don't
want to touch some of his ideas because
of.
Not that he's talking about anything
really controversial at the end of the
day,
they don't want to touch it,
but it's because of the professor of the
PR pressure from the students or is this
coming first?
I think it's coming first from the
professors or or even whatever is above
that.
I don't know if it's the
administration's or even whatever is
above that.
Like I don't know how high you have to
go with it,
but I don't think it's the kids that are
doing it.
I think they are being fed shit and
they're being fed fear and stupidity and
then they just bow,
you know,
they just sort of rally around is also a
real problem in colleges.
I believe that these people that operate
in academia,
I've only worked in Ghana and they don't
really understand the real world because
they aren't in it and they're in a
position of power with young people,
so their ideas have incredible
influence.
They're standing on this stage,
teat teaching these lectures,
teaching these classes,
and they have these young impressionable
people that are listening to them just
gives them a gigantic ego boost.
They have this platform and they have
never competed in the real world.
They've never contributed to the real
world other than teaching children.
And there's a lot of them like that that
have gone through the educational system
and then gone from the educational
system directly to teaching and then
this is their,
this is their universe and this is how
they exist and these people are pretty
much all part of the regressive left.
They are pretty much all parties.
So if you could think,
here's a simple example of this,
so there's a difference between debating
ideas and hate speech.
So let's say somebody that that hated
Muslim people want it to speak at a
college and it was going to talk about
how we should kick them out of the
country or we should whatever horrible
things to them,
I could see absolutely protest that
person.
Use Your right of free speech and free
assembly to protest that person's ideas.
Should the college not let them come.
You know,
if it was purely hate,
I suppose.
But I know that that's a really slippery
slope because everyone,
you know,
versus you could take any of these
people ion Hirsi Ali,
she's not against Muslim people.
She's against the doctrine,
these ideas.
And if we can't make the distinction
between hate speech and someone who
wants to debate ideas,
if you can't do that in college,
then where the hell else can you?
Not only that,
try getting some inflammatory quotes by
Ian Hirsi Ali that you could argue
against that aren't live really well
thought out,
that aren't articulate,
that aren't based on her personal
experiences growing up in this religion.
Her understanding of the scripture like
try,
try finding some ignorant Hayden that
you're not going to.
These guys don't want to debate ideas.
It's really as simple as that.
So at the very personal level I can tell
you.
So you've had Janken.
He was my former boss for two years at
tyt.
He watched the original thing with Sam
and then sat down with him for three
hours.
Did you see any of that shit?
I watched the whole thing.
Three hours.
I watched that thing.
I was working for him at the time.
Literally like my.
I was like this the entire time because
I was having a headache because I could
not believe that this person that I
worked for who I respect,
who I play basketball with every Sunday,
that he was so dense to the ideas that
Sam was portraying.
And at the end of it,
just as I said to you before that at the
end of mine,
I thought I had made this conversation a
little bit better.
Jank only doubled down on all of this
shit because they don't want to debate
ideas.
They want,
they just want Sam to be discredited so
that their ideas when.
And that's why we have to fight against
it.
Because if sam disappears,
as I said earlier,
if Sam disappears tomorrow,
it's not about him.
It's about all the ideas that will all
be afraid to talk about.
That's why Charlie Hebdo cartoons,
you should be able to,
family guy can do whatever the fuck they
want on Jesus.
Right?
Every episode,
there's a,
you know,
there's an episode where Jesus is
bathing with porn music in the
background in front of [inaudible] a
baby.
Nobody had a problem with that.
Try doing that with Mohammed.
But we can't have,
we can't just pick,
you can pick,
say whatever the fuck you want about
Judaism.
Big Goddamn deal.
What is it with Cenk?
What I mean,
you,
you know,
um,
I,
that,
that was really perplexing to me because
I usually feel like you were there are
agree with him or don't agree with him
on other things.
I feel like he's,
you know,
he's got an opinion,
he thinks about it,
he talks about it,
he tries to be open minded,
he's passionate about these ideas,
but with that it was so confusing to me
because it was almost like he was just
trying to win,
look like he was trying to find a way to
beat someone who is,
you know,
Samson intellectual black belt,
like a high level world champion black
belts of the spoken word.
And I think that Jank it's not at the
same level of Sam when they come when it
comes to debating these ideas at one
point about 20 minutes in Sam does lays
out some basic probability stuff and
yanked your says he doesn't believe in
it.
I mean that,
that sort of explains it right there.
Like Sam wasn't laying out a plan.
He was just saying this is sorta how
probability works.
And Jack was like,
no,
I don't.
I don't believe in it.
I don't know.
And just for the record,
I get no pleasure even talking about
this because you know,
you know,
you know what it's like.
Did you debate Cenk or having a
conversation with him off the air?
No,
we didn't because it just,
it just never materialized,
you know what I mean?
A lot of times when,
although I did do the main young Turk
show with him a lot,
most of the time because I was on it,
it was because he was out of town,
so I was either filling in or something
like that.
So there wasn't really the forum for
that.
Um,
and then it really had a lot to do with
why I left because I just could not
believe it that,
I mean there's,
there's people that have edited things
where Jake says one thing directly to
Sam's face and then days later is saying
the complete reverse thing.
Sitting down with Reza Aslan and saying
that,
yeah,
he means all Muslims.
And it's like,
ugh.
You just said to his face,
you just said to his face that,
you know,
that's not what he says and I think it's
partly,
it goes to that AFLAC thing that he's
trying to be this,
he's trying to defend Muslim people that
he feels are being abused and,
and there's a lofty goal there
somewhere,
but if you use the tactics of dishonesty
and slander and smearing and all that to
get there,
you,
it's not good.
It's not good.
So I don't know.
It's awful.
But I really liked him.
That's what fucks me up.
I,
I feel completely the same way and
actually I am.
So when I left I just left the thing be
and I was like,
all right,
that's it.
You know,
I left,
we left on good terms,
we went out to breakfast,
we were good to go,
and then he just kept on twitter,
kept lying about it,
misrepresenting ideas and people and
tons of his own fans were turning on
him.
So I just finally,
after months I was like,
I can't take this anymore.
I've got to do something.
And I didn't know.
I didn't know what to do because you
know,
it's like,
it's like here's a friend,
here's a coworker,
a contemporary,
like how do I do this in a respectful
way?
And finally one night I laid out like
eight or 10 tweets in a row.
I thought them all through first and I
was like,
Jack,
here's what I think is going on because
I needed it to be public because if I
had just sent them an email,
I've,
you know,
he could either not respond to respond,
but what does that do at the end of the
day if me and him get to our mayor
Kulpa,
but it's not public,
right?
So in a very respectful and not
attacking me,
I laid out some stuff.
He completely ignored it.
A couple of weeks went by,
finally I did something and finally he
responded,
but then just kept doing the same shit.
So I don't know what the answer is but
I.
But this is what Glenn is done.
This is what Rez is done.
I don't get it.
I looked.
These are tactics,
these are tactics they're using to win.
Marginalized was right on my show who
cowrote sandblast book,
it was a discussion about Islam called
the future of tolerance Islam in the
future of tolerance.
So I'm pretty sure these are people on
the side of tolerance,
right?
Majid,
who by the way has been treated worse
than anybody,
you know,
like one of these guys that works at,
at,
uh,
the intercept for Glen called a Mojito
porch monkey while he was sitting next
to Sam.
You know what I mean?
Like,
because you,
oh,
you don't believe what we think you're
supposed to believe as a Muslim person
and you're with an atheist,
you're his porch monkey.
I mean,
think if that came from the right,
how we would rightly react,
react to that or how these guys on the
left you would react to that.
Um,
so anyway,
so,
so sadly,
and that's what leaves me with such like
conflict here is that I don't think it's
going to stop.
And I,
and I think they've learned,
you know what?
What's that Hitler quote?
Like,
the bigger the lie,
the more people will believe it.
I think they're partly operating on
that,
that the opportunity cost for Sam,
for you,
for me,
for anyone that cares about any of this,
to clean up the mess is is way too much
for just up Sam's racist.
That's the one that's easy,
but now same to clean it up and it's.
And it's a two hour frustrated
conversation that he had and yeah,
as you said,
if you listen to it fucking brilliant,
brilliant.
It was a two hour conversation that is
trying to balance out x amount of months
of disinformation,
but I think that ultimately in the long
run his ideas are more accurate.
They're more like what he's saying is
well thought through and his opinions
are better considered.
I when you
cannot,
cannot made it through one with you.
What with me?
Sure.
And it wasn't at one and it looked at
one to the point that I,
as I said before,
I think there's a tipping point coming
because I do think our site is getting
stronger.
I really do.
But the amount of effort and energy he
has had to put into this and when you
see.
I think it's.
There's a chilling effect when they,
when people see the ad,
I'm not talking about us.
When the average person sees what has
happened to this guy again,
you've sat with him for probably 20
hours,
never thought he was a racist before.
When the average person sees what
they've done to him,
it causes the average person not to want
to speak about something.
I get emails.
I'm sure you get them.
I got an email a couple of days ago from
someone in Sweden saying,
I am terrified to talk about any of this
stuff.
I'm terrified to talk about what's
happening in my country right now.
You know,
and,
and I'm getting emails from all over
literally all way from Saudi Arabia and
all over the place.
People saying you're talking about stuff
that people are afraid to talk about.
I'm not doing it for any other reason
other than I feel like I have to.
It's not.
You know what I mean?
Like I feel like I'm on this road
because it,
it just appeared before me.
If this wasn't where I really wanted to
go,
my standard was a lot about transformers
and gi Joe.
Stupid Shit,
right?
I don't know.
Yeah.
I don't know either.
I don't know either,
but I think that when guys like Jank do
say things that are easily discredited.
When you say like,
look,
you said this one thing two days ago
when you were talking to Sam,
now you're saying something completely
different when he's not here.
That is so bad for people's perception
of your ideas.
It's so bad for your own credibility.
It's so bad when you express opinions
about other things,
like you can say something like,
as a comic you can say things and you
can joke around them and I can know that
you're joking so I can I.
okay.
He doesn't really believe that and
you're fucking around,
but that's this.
This isn't fucking around.
So you're being held to your ideas,
your ideas.
You're held accountable for your ideas
and when your ideas are massively
inconsistent and contrary days later and
when you are expressing an idea that you
have to know is incorrect.
So that's the part that I don't
understand because look,
I have fucked up,
we've all done fucked up things in our
life.
We've all,
we've all lied,
we've all,
whatever I have.
Maybe you bro,
not you,
not you.
I know.
We've,
we've asked yourself,
we've all made mistakes.
You know,
look,
Brian Williams made some stupid part ego
mistake,
part,
whatever you want to call it.
A and then only found like 15 different
but everything being equal,
they weren't like cataclysmic lies in
the scheme of what,
uh,
you know what I mean in the scheme of
things,
they were about his little adventures
that he exaggerated partly because of
the media because the media wants you to
be a star two.
So he has to go on the tonight show and
talk about being on a helicopter.
Went actually,
would Walter Cronkite have done that?
Probably.
I don't know.
I've got a friend,
Steve Reynolds easy and I think,
you know,
his story,
the nine slash 11 story.
Um,
and I,
I think they're really similar.
The Brian Williams thing and that like
both original stories.
We're actually pretty impressive and
these guys doctored them up and turned
them into this epic thing that
ultimately cost them a shitload of
credibility,
if not all their credibility with Brian
Williams.
He was actually in a fucking helicopter
in Iraq.
The helicopter in front of them was shot
at.
So like,
that's scary as fuck.
You're a reporter,
you're getting shot at you,
you're hearing gunshots.
Go off the people in front of you or a
hit.
That's a good story.
Your helicopter had to get hit though
because ultimately these people are full
of shit and they have to exaggerate and,
and,
and jazz it up.
They don't.
And because of that,
you can't trust what they're saying.
Right.
So then that,
then it has that effect where you go at
this guy did this one.
Exactly,
but think about it.
Actually my point was actually the
reverse of that because what I was going
to say is that his,
his lies were little additional details,
you know,
like a little.
I'm a little cooler details what these
guys have done have been too blatantly
distort.
Yeah.
Someone's views.
So we talked to you about opponent.
That's the difference,
right?
Because it's a competition between
Jenkins,
Sam.
Right.
So,
so what do you do with that?
So what do I can't?
Well,
I,
I like junk but I'm not turning to him
for advice or ideas.
Now I can't.
I mean that's how I listened to his.
When I listened to his opinions about
things I unfortunately have to take into
consideration that has been massively
inconsistent about this one thing.
So when,
when someone is caught or exposure,
whatever you want to call it,
to have so severely misrepresented
someone else's views,
how were you able to separate that from
the other,
the rest?
So let's say you like 80 percent of his
views or anybody would have to make it
about him.
How,
how do you separate that out?
Because I,
at this point,
I don't know how I do it at all and I
know Sam has said that about Glen.
Even when it comes to the,
uh,
the NSA stuff,
he's like,
I don't know what to make of that now
because I know what this person is
capable of.
I think that's a really interesting
point.
It's a very interesting point and it's a
very important point because I have
people on this podcast all the time that
I don't agree with and I want to hear
their thoughts.
I want to know why.
I had this conversation with Mark Marin
the other night at the comedy store and
he was like,
why'd you have that guy on?
You know that guys have this,
and then he said that because I want to
find out what makes them tick.
I want to find out what goes on his head
that goes on in his head,
but there's a difference between someone
I don't agree with and someone who I
know is distorting that use of another
person,
like changing someone's words,
changing someone's intent and and doing
it for their own benefit,
doing it so that they can win this
ideological conversation,
this argument that that becomes a real
issue and there also becomes a real
issue.
Like what if I having a conversation
with you and then two weeks later you
distort what I say?
Exactly.
I don't want to do that.
I don't.
I don't want to have to defend my ideas
because you've mislabeled them or ms.ms
dot,
you know,
misconstrued.
You know,
it's funny.
It's also what is so cool about being in
the digital space because as I said,
people are first off,
people are clipping things.
You can clip on twitter,
here's what you did,
here's what you did and they can explain
to them,
so first off you've empowered the people
at the bottom of this that are just
consuming it are now able to get their
voices heard,
to fight the bullshit and I think that
there has been a real wave with that
which is incredibly inspiring to me.
It's so different than ever before and
look,
see if someone came on here.
If I come on here and I said something
that was profoundly dishonest or was
smearing of someone else,
I would never hear the end of it and and
hopefully people would tag you on
twitter and you retweet the shit out of
it until everybody had seen.
You see what fucking Rubin did and
whatever.
Now I'm pretty sure that's not going to
have not the end of this,
but when you don't,
it doesn't benefit.
You know,
it doesn't benefit because you can be.
That's what I don't understand about
these guys.
How can you do this?
How can you retweet memes?
Implying that Sam wants to a nuclear
entire Middle East.
When you first of all,
you know his whole thing on nuking the
first right thing.
It's at the end of end of faith.
It's about a page and a half.
That's how much time he spent on this
topic and they've made it sound like
this is his bucket and go to his
position and he's.
He's talking about a horrific scenario
or some isis type civilization has
control of nuclear weapons and there's a
real threat that they're going to use
them on other people.
That's what he's talking about.
Apocalyptic regime.
You asked what he's talking.
You have to consider that.
If that's possibility,
if it's a possibility that there could
be a regime like that somewhere in the
world,
you have to say,
well,
what would we do?
What are the options?
What could you do in that scenario to
not debate that is to like dig your head
in the sand and that's.
That's the bigger problem.
What do you think Barack Obama thinks on
this?
We have nukes right now.
We know we have new because we're the
only country that's used nukes.
Do you think that Barack Obama would
only wait until we were nuked to use
nukes?
Probably not.
Right?
I don't know.
I mean I couldn't,
no matter how much discussion there.
Yeah,
there's a discussion there and I think
that's the.
That's the deal.
It's like a discussion.
I think when you discredit people would
be dishonest statements.
When you say things that you know are
not true,
it becomes a huge issue.
Not not like what you're talking about.
When you said,
well,
I'm pretty sure no one's gonna find
contradictory statements by me.
Well,
it's because there's no benefit in it.
Yeah.
Like you like is not going to really
gain points by distorting Sam's
perspectives on things.
He is only going to gain points with
people who don't actually know Sam's
perspective.
He's going to lose massively when people
do listen to what Sam says.
Yeah,
because then you all of a sudden,
whatever goodwill and whatever,
love and appreciation for your ideas,
that's going to go out the window when
they find out that your ideas have been
distorted,
that your your points of view rather of
other people's ideas.
I've been distorted.
Yeah.
I've had that happen to me on this show.
I show with a guy that I actually like.
Even though he did this sky,
Jamie Kilstein and ancillary.
We did.
He's a social justice warrior.
The whole deal.
I don't think he's a bad guy.
I really don't.
I like them as human being.
I,
every time I talked to him,
I enjoy talking to them,
but we did a podcast to get together and
we disagreed on a bunch of things.
Then when he went on his podcast and
completely distorted everything that I
said and changed the entire conversation
to him being a victim,
which is,
which is one.
Oh,
one one.
and then this guy online put together
the actual conversation and Jamie's
perception of the conversation and it
said it was,
I forget the Kilstein delusion.
It was the name of the video and because
of that he received so much fucking hate
and I think that made him aware of that
and he said it was the low moment of his
life and he completely good stop doing
that and he doesn't do any of that shit
anymore and you know,
he's rebounded and now he's happier than
he's ever been before.
But I think that that type of behavior
is not to standard.
It's accepted.
It's almost expected,
you know,
it's like what they do and that's if
you're a part of that victim culture,
the perpetual victim culture,
that's how you do it,
you,
you make it seem like people were
yelling at you and there's people and
they were so upset with me and all I was
doing was trying to say that women
shouldn't be raped.
That's not what happened.
Not what happened.
That must've been incredibly validating
for you.
Right?
Like because it,
because it's personal too,
and that that's why you can see my body
language probably when I talk about Jake
doesn't,
I get no pleasure out of this.
This is not how I see.
I didn't go to work for this guy and
agree with so much of,
you know,
get money out of politics.
You know,
his,
his core stuff.
I didn't go there for my feelings
ultimately to be this,
but that's where we're at.
So in a case like you're talking about
with Jamie,
it's extremely validating that you
create a space based on a certain amount
of principles.
Someone goes against them,
your audience then calls them out and
then there's like a teachable moment to
him.
It's pretty good,
pretty great.
I think in that way it's great.
I don't,
I didn't take any pleasure in the fact
that he got fucked up emotionally
because of it or not that the hate that
you get online,
especially if you're like a super
sensitive person that's really trolling
for love.
You know all your fucking lines in the
water and you're trolling for love.
That's what you're doing.
And in saying that,
and even becoming this victim,
you're trolling for love.
I mean,
it's,
you're trying to do,
trying to get people to fuck Joe Rogan.
Fuck that.
Transphobic,
homophobic,
racist,
sexist,
misogynistic,
asshole.
Like throw them all out there,
throw them all out there.
I mean,
but that's what's what,
what's going on when someone's.
And you got to realize that when you
distort people's perceptions or distort
people's positions for your own personal
benefit,
you do yourself a horrible disservice
because you now have ruined any
validity,
any,
anything that you have in the past that
may resonate with people.
You've ruined that because now you've
poisoned that well.
Yeah.
So it can be so laid out clearly like
this.
Let's say that two of the five things
that Sam,
you know,
those controversial things.
So the profiling thing,
right?
Um,
or we belaboring this point because I
think it's so there's so much to it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
but let's say Sam would argue that
because these are debatable ideas,
we should debate them.
So imagine if subsequently so they do
the three hours,
sit down,
he and Jane and after that instead of
saying he wants to profile Muslim Ba,
Ba and Ba,
ba Ba and all that bravado and bullshit
and whatever.
I imagine if he had said,
you know,
Sam and I really disagree on this,
I fear that Sam's use of anti profiling,
we're profiling whatever you want to
call it.
I fear that ultimately it will lead if
you know for,
for good and you know the road to hell
is paved with good intentions.
I think that he's trying to do something
good,
but ultimately it's going to lead to
Muslim people feeling persecuted,
feeling like the other.
But if he had laid that out like that
and had an intellectually honest say,
we believe different things here and
that's okay.
You have a pretty great place to be.
Yes,
you have a pretty fucking great place to
be.
People who who prayer pretty much agree
on most things and that we can move
forward and go,
we disagree.
But when you do what he did,
you've,
you've just,
you've ransacked the playing field and
now and now you just have burned
bullshit and that's what it's become.
So that's why when you mentioned Kyle's
podcast,
that's why Sam,
that's as frustrated as I've ever heard
him,
but as you said,
it was still pretty eloquent and pretty
elegant,
but he's pissed.
He's pissed and I think rightly so.
And that's why,
that's why I've been so defensive over
the guy because I know it's like,
let's have this,
if we can do this now.
It's only gonna get worse.
I have as well.
I mean I've been very defensive with
them as well and unfortunately I have a
good friend,
Abby Martin that I love dearly as well,
but she and Sam have gone back and forth
about this and I think she in some ways
distorts his perceptions.
I mean,
I've seen,
I've seen her story.
I don't know her that well,
so I don't want to.
I love her.
She's awesome.
I've seen her,
the stored a lot of facts on air to talk
about,
about different things.
She gets very passionate and I think
sometimes she misses the mark on certain
things,
but she's a very good person and I think
she's ultimately,
she has all the right intentions,
but the intention is to have the pay the
road to hell,
those fucking things.
You see what I'm saying?
That yes it is.
It's like with a guy like Genco,
I think he's his own worst enemy in that
regard because once you start doing
that,
then you have to sort of double down
just to try to figure out a more
eloquent way of reestablishing your
position and when you do that,
like people don't take you seriously
anymore.
That's the problem.
That's a real problem.
You become your own enemy.
Yeah.
You throw out that bomb of bullshit and
now you're not going to be.
There was a point,
there is time.
Look,
if you said something that was
completely untrue or,
or you smeared somebody,
right,
and then two weeks later you thought it
through.
Even if you.
Even if you knew you were lying when you
did it,
but two weeks later you're like,
wow,
I really shouldn't have done that.
Like I intended to do something good
there.
You could backtrack with the value that
you have in your name and your fans.
They would follow you back.
Yeah.
A couple of people will be like,
fuck him,
but.
But people would go and if you calmly
explained what happened,
you could.
The problem with these guys is they've
gone and they kept going and kept going
and kept going,
but they're so off the range now.
In my view,
there's nothing they could do to ever
fix this situation.
It's like a guy,
I know where I'm going,
but you really don't,
and then you just keep saying,
I know where you're going.
Your last further and further in the
woods.
Like,
dude,
you're so far from the fucking road.
Now you're going to have to shoot
yourself and come back as a baby and
lived your life again because this is a
disaster we created.
Yeah.
I just.
I don't know.
I don't.
I don't know how to fix that,
but I know what it is when I see it.
Yeah.
Well I think this is fixing it.
I think this is fixing that.
That's actually when I woke up this
morning and even when I went to bed last
night,
I was like in a great place because I
was like,
I knew I wanted to have this
conversation and I try.
I've had it in little bites on my show,
but I don't like.
Not that this has really been about me
because this is about some big stuff,
but we're having more of a of a lofty
thing here.
Then it is about you in a way because
you're a part of this big stuff and also
when you're doing your show like the
Rubin report,
what you're doing is you're expressing
yourself and you become a credible
portal to these ideas and information.
So it is about you in a way because it's
about all of us and it's about your
credibility as that portal and you,
you.
You have to defend that,
that that's fucking.
Look,
I'm wrong about shit all the time,
but if I'm wrong about shit,
dude,
I'm the first person to tell you I'm
wrong about it because I'm horrified if
I.
unless it's some simple stupid mistake,
but when I'm.
When I'm making.
If I make a mistake,
I want to be the first guy to talk about
it.
I don't,
I don't want anybody believing anything
that's not true to help my ego.
So you've had a carer,
Santa Maria on her.
So she's,
she's a good friend of mine,
worked with me at tea lover and I am
not.
Yeah,
I love her too.
She's fantastic.
And she is a science communicator.
That's the way she describes herself.
Um,
I think she had something to do with
this brain surgery life thing last
night.
Yes.
I machio yes.
So she's doing really good stuff and I
really respect her in Laker a many.
I've said to my audience many times,
you know,
I know a lot about politics,
garden beds,
all this stuff.
I'm not a science guy,
like,
you know,
I can understand basic stuff,
but I'm not a scientist.
So I have to trust people that know
about science to tell me things.
So many times I've brought her on just
to clean up messes that I've made.
Sure.
So I never go with the,
uh,
I never go with the presumption to my
audience that I know everything about
everything.
I'm going to bring on some people and
look then.
So when I've done things on GMO is with
Cara,
she,
she is,
uh,
she firmly believes in Gmos and that's a
whole,
that's a whole other thing,
right?
But I know a lot of people don't like
her stance on Gmos,
but I say,
here's my science person,
here's what she said about this,
and I'm actually trying to find someone
that's a little more against GMO is now
to come on and refute some of that
stuff.
We don't have as the interviewer,
as the guy on this side of it.
We don't have to know everything,
which is what you said before that that
does give us a little bit of a leash,
right?
Because we're sitting across from
someone and we're just bouncing ideas.
We're also talking about so many
different subjects.
It's impossible to be an expert in all
of that.
Yeah.
I guess this actually goes to your point
about the format of realtime and all
these shows that look at,
look at where we bounced here already.
You know what I mean?
There's only a couple areas where I feel
real comfortable and saying I'm an
expert,
I'm an expert in stand up comedy and I'm
an expert in martial arts and even in
martial arts there's,
there's certain aspects of martial arts
where I have to defer to other experts.
Yeah.
You know,
there's just too many styles.
There's too many different.
There's,
you know,
there's some different weird Filipinos.
There's C lot,
there's different stick fighting styles
and like you can't know everything.
You can't.
Well you can't,
not only can't know anything,
but if you want to see how the thing
that you consider yourself an expert in
how it,
how it all sort of leads to one road,
look what you did with men because you
had a set of principles,
right?
You had a set of principles in something
that you love.
Stand up.
Right?
I mean,
is there anything you love more than
stand up beside wife and kids?
Like,
is that it?
Yeah,
friend's wife,
kids health,
but in terms of the other things like
standards,
right?
Yeah.
And,
and,
and what you did with Mensa,
which I'm sure you've talked about a
bajillion times already.
Uh,
do you remember we met one to actually
know what did we meet?
We met at the young Turks.
You were going to do an air show and we
were,
we were talking for a few minutes and
obviously I knew who you were,
but I didn't want.
I'm a comic too,
like I just didn't.
So we just shot the shit for a few
minutes and we talked about that a
little bit,
but my point is that because you,
you used the set of principles that are
guiding you right now to do this show
are the same principles that you use to
defend your art in,
in that moment,
you know,
so all of these things,
they all come together one way or
another.
In some ways.
The real problem with that men,
a thing was that the art form is being
compromised,
not just by him stealing from other
people,
but him creating an environment where
people are terrified to express
themselves.
Like I mean,
look at that social justice warrior,
right?
That's the same thing that they've done
by jake yelling racist.
Now what have you done?
Most sort of.
He was.
You couldn't express yourself because he
would steal those ideas and call them
his own and that's why I think there was
literally like a signal that people
would do where you'd be on stage for
five minutes.
He had a 15 minute set and all of a
sudden five minutes in the light would
be on like,
why is the light on?
I have 10 more minutes ago.
It was [inaudible] been ceos in the room
and they would let people know that
flashed the light.
Well,
it was.
It was a problem.
It was a real problem.
It's also the people that were running
the comedy store.
We're fucking retarded as well as the
people that were running these agencies
were fucking retarded.
Like the
conversation that I had with my agents
when they were telling me that I had to
either apologize to him or they were
going to drop me.
I go,
do you guys understand what you're
doing?
Because you're making a decision right
now.
You're calling it business.
You're making a decision that's going to
affect the rest of your life.
You're supporting criminal and all you
sell is art.
All you sell is art.
It's all you guys do.
You don't.
You don't produce widgets.
You guys aren't building cars.
You guys are set your sellers of other
people's art.
That's what an agent is and what you
have here is a guy who's stealing art
and selling it.
You have a vampire and you're.
You're taking this vampire.
He will suck the blood of the creative
geniuses that you have on your roster.
But meanwhile the opposite has happened.
Louis C,
k left them immediately.
David tell left them.
Nick Swardson left them with people that
found out about them.
What?
Fuck this.
Then he left them.
So the whole thing was a disaster for
Gersh from the agency at the time and
you know that they've really never
recovered.
I mean it's,
it's always a little bit.
I left for other reasons.
It was a fucking disaster for them.
I mean,
they lost a fuck load of money because
of that one conversation that we had
over the phone where I would've stayed
with them.
I'm like,
if you want to defend this Douche bag,
you know,
I don't give a fuck.
I've been my agent for years.
You know,
I liked the guy who,
I'm not going to name him,
he's a good dude.
But he was being put into position by
the guy who owned the company that like,
look,
this guy is calling me up saying he
demands that,
that joe apologize to him and he wants
it to be a big deal and like,
fuck you.
I'm like,
I'd rather be homeless.
And basically for people to really
understand that the reason was because
at the time he was a bigger star than
you.
Right.
That's where the power play was.
He was on.
But I was big enough star that I
couldn't be hurt by it.
It was rich.
I'm like,
what are you going to do?
I was on fear factor at the time.
I had all this money and I'm like,
you can't hurt me.
And he tried.
He tried to get me.
He got me banned from the comedy store.
He tried to get my agency and this is a
person in me where I'm already
untouchable in that sense,
like really can't.
You really can't dig in.
Like,
what are you going to do?
You're going to try though.
So if I was a young comic coming up,
he would have had some real damage.
He could have done some real damage to
me.
Well,
I'm sure there's probably untold amount
of young comics that he lifted from that
you have no idea of.
Well,
a lot of them contacted me while that
was going on and some of them didn't
want to be named and some of them didn't
mind if I named them.
But I think honestly that most likely he
stole almost everything he did and that
he stole it from different sources.
And change it around,
but you've got that with a lot of
comics.
You've got that over with a lot of,
a lot of,
like really shitty comedians make it.
And one of the ways they make is they
take other people's ideas and they move
them around.
Just enough.
Look even good comics.
Look,
Robin Williams,
who's,
you know,
has more talent or had more talented his
finger then I probably have been my
whole body.
And that's well known deal.
I know,
I know a comment personally,
you probably know them too,
but I won't name him for the purpose of
this,
but who,
uh,
Robin's
stole a bit from,
didn't he never told him but then just
sent him a check.
You send him a $15,000
check.
He did that.
So a lot of guys will get better as a
performer than he was as a creative guy.
Someone who came up with the ideas
you've ever heard that phrase.
Parallel evolution has that.
Uh,
so I had a comic when I was working in
New York that I worked with almost every
night and he started lifting from people
and we all kind of knew at any,
did exactly what you said it was like he
would take the premise but then just
tweak it enough that every time I'd be
watching I'd go can't,
you know,
like,
but,
but we all knew and one night I finally
confronted him,
he's still doing standard by the way,
and we've since become friends and he
sort of apologized and whatever.
And he said to me one night,
he goes,
Dave,
don't you know about parallel evolution.
The premise being that with these jokes
just evolve over,
you know,
if you're talking about sort of current
event type things,
we're all going to,
a certain amount of it's just going to
evolve at the same time was.
And I said,
I was about to say his name,
but I said,
uh,
I said,
not only are you lifting jokes,
you also made up a theory that's pretty
good.
If you could apply that sort of creative
thinking to your jokes,
maybe we wouldn't be in this problem and
that is part of the problem is that a
lot of these people,
they have a self defeating tendency and
that's self defeating tendency is that
they don't.
They're not willing to put in the work
because they're afraid of failure,
so instead they see success and they
just duplicate it and they literally
duplicated in the premise,
duplicate the premises.
They duplicate the pathway to getting to
the end of the joke,
but the one thing they can't duplicate
is,
you know what I mean,
and that that's at the end of the day,
that's all we have.
Forget whether it's stand up or whether
it's radio or on your,
like what you have.
The thing that at the end of the day
they come to you is something that you
can't really quantify,
right?
Like you just people understand a
certain series of things about you that
they like.
So if the average person,
why do you like Rogan?
They could lay out a couple of things,
but there's that other thing that just
is there.
They can't duplicate you bought in the
case of a guy like Robin Williams.
He can do all the things that you do
that people like.
Well,
it becomes a problem because if he goes
on before you.
And that was one of the things that he
would do,
he would steal someone's bit and then
bring them on because the comedy store,
you tag team,
you would go on and you would say,
thank you very much.
Good night.
All right this next comment because you
know,
and you'd bring up your friend,
right?
So no MC,
no Mc at the comedy store.
And he would bring on guys right after
he did their closing bit and he would do
it to fuck with them and he would do it
because he had some power,
you know?
And because the Mexican community is
desperately looking for star Comedians,
I mean they have a,
they have a few of them.
Like George Lopez was always a big one.
And Gabriel,
Gabriel Iglesias is a big one.
He sells out everywhere,
but he's a really nice guy.
And the difference being that men,
ceos,
not really Mexican,
that was,
you know,
it was,
he was completely concocted.
Yeah.
And that's what really did him in more
than anything,
it was a fake name.
What?
Wait,
what was Israel?
Israeli illness.
And what about,
what's the other one?
Uh,
the one of the redneck guys were
electric bob or frigerators south.
The cable guy.
And what's his real name?
And he said,
Dan Whitney.
And it's like,
yeah.
But Dan was jokes.
Yeah.
I don't mind someone like dice clay's
real name was in dice clay.
Andrew Silverstein.
I was at a party a couple of weeks ago
and a dice was there and I was never a
huge,
huge fan of his.
But I do remember around whatever that
was,
maybe 89 slash 90,
maybe a little later when he sold out
the garden.
And when he was in that,
you know,
that year of just sanity.
I remember watching that and thinking
like,
this is incredible.
Like it was one of the things that
really sparked me with standup because
even though I didn't love the material
and I understood that how stupid the
jokes were sort of,
but I was like,
the power of this is fucking amazing.
And so I went up to him at this party
and I tapped my shoulder and I just
said,
Dave comic,
Blah Blah.
He was like,
yeah,
good.
And then walked away.
Like I was like,
wow.
Because I've had such good.
I'm sure you've had this too when you,
when you've met comics over the years
that you really admire.
Pretty much every single one that I've
ever admired.
When I lived on the upper west in New
York,
I lived about two blocks away from
Seinfeld,
so I'd bumped into him a lot and he was
a little hot and cold,
but like basically like there was the
comic bond,
you know what I mean?
Like,
yeah.
And I was just,
dice was just,
he was so over it.
That's unfortunate because he's become
his persona.
Well,
he's dressed them,
but you know,
he wasn't always that guy like that
dressing,
that whole thing.
That was a character in Andrew
Silverstein's act like the dice man was
a guy who would do that was basically
Jerry Lewis and the nutty professor.
Like if you've never seen the nutty
professor,
it's a great movie and one of the things
that's great about it,
it's Jerry Lewis is like this nerdy guy
who takes a potion that was approached
and it becomes this super cool daddio
guy,
you know,
this is like 19 fucking whatever it was.
50 something probably,
and it's a hilarious movie because you
know,
ultimately this guy becomes this guy
that the ladies love and then the
promotion starts wearing off and he goes
back to being as nerdy self again and
dice is that guy.
I mean,
that's,
that's who he is on stage.
While it was only a part of his act and
then it became the best part of his act
and then it became his act.
Then it became him outside.
So like,
so now you see him walking around the
street,
he's got the weightlifting gloves on.
He just got a jacket with the fucking.
It's got all the glitter on it and shut.
It's be dazzled.
I mean,
it's,
he's A.
I,
I have,
I'm happy he exists though.
I enjoy him for sure.
And think about like the fact that at
that if you watch that Madison Square
Garden special,
that all on youtube,
you can watch it.
People are announcing the jokes before
he even finishes the premise.
That was the power.
That's where it showed to me the power
of standup.
Like I always loved.
I remember what got me into standup was
I was four years old,
1986,
maybe 19,
83.
I saw bill cosby himself on Hbo and I
was on the floor even though I probably
don't even really understand what he was
talking about.
I thought this was the greatest thing
ever.
You know,
you're growing up by the way,
when your childhood hero becomes a
serial rapist,
most successful series of all time.
Yeah.
Um,
but that,
that sparked it in me,
that sparked laughter and,
and wanting to make people laugh and
loving comedy for me.
Uh,
but the nice thing was like,
Holy Shit,
this is a real.
Now I understand the show to um,
well his standup was different in that
not only did you know the punchline but
the whole lines would sing a song.
Yeah.
So they wanted to hear the same jokes
again,
which is very different from other
standup with stand up most of the time.
You want to hear the new bits.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
people want to hear shit they haven't
heard before and I know that even
talking about Cosby,
it's hard to do at this point because
everyone associates such terrible stuff.
But I did see him live a couple of times
and one of the most amazing things that
I ever saw a comic do ever was that,
you know,
everyone knew that whole himself
special.
Every comic loved it.
Pretty much.
So many from Chris Rock,
the Seinfeld to a zillion people credit
that with like being one of their
seminal things and the records and all
that.
And I saw cosby maybe 10 years ago in
Jersey and he was doing all new stuff
and you know,
it was kind of,
you know,
by his last 10 years,
haven't been that kind to him and even
just the way he looks and he's had some
health things,
like just what none of it was that
great.
But then at the end he goes,
I'm going to do one old bit for you.
And he said,
I know you all know it.
I know you all know it,
but I'm gonna do one little bit for you.
And he did the dentist routine and
everyone knew it,
but he was such a master that he was,
it was like watching him.
It was like watching someone with clay
because he could take the last before
they were coming and then just change it
enough to keep them going more.
And they weren't yelling out the
punchlines because it wasn't as,
you know,
like didactic or just set as,
as a dice.
But like it was,
it was amazing to watch to do comedy and
invent your old bit that you've now
reinvented a thousand times.
And they know it all and it was like as
good as ever it was,
it was amazing to watch his old stuff.
I mean in the time it's.
And that is a thing that you need to
take into consideration when you watch
standup standup,
a sort of a,
it's sort of a time machine.
It's a time capsule and like that's why
you can go back and listen to Lenny
Bruce who is arguably the most important
standup comic ever.
And he's not very funny.
Yeah.
It's just not,
it's not very good today.
And this is coming from someone who has
lenny bruce posters framed in his house
and I have Lenny Bruce live at the
fillmore in,
in my,
uh,
my office.
I mean she's,
in my opinion,
the most important guy ever.
Well he changed the art definitely
simply.
He just fucking tore that thing down.
We are not going to do jokes like that.
We're going to talk about real shit.
And he opened it for everybody,
period.
And I think that's often the case with a
lot of the greats.
Like a lot of the old Carlin stuff is in
that vein,
like a,
I understand its position in the,
but if you watch it or listen to it
today,
it's really not that good.
You know,
it's interesting the case with Cosby as
well,
so,
so cosby for a while and especially now
cosby has this other thing attached to
them that it's,
it just becomes impossible to remove it.
It's so lined up together.
Carlin,
so I had Kelly Carlin on this week was a
George's daughter who's a good friend of
mine and we talked a lot.
We talked about that and we related at
all to everything else we've been
talking about here,
the social justice stuff and language
and words and you know,
being afraid to hear certain ideas and
all that.
So it was really,
really interesting conversation.
And uh,
I watched a bunch of Georgia stuff just
in preparation.
I've seen it all a thousand times,
but I thought actually a lot of it's
still does some of it.
Yeah,
the seven dirty words sorta seemed
ridiculous now in a certain way,
but it's still pretty good.
Like,
and even his last hbo special is fucking
perfection.
It,
I,
I've asked her this before.
He knew his health was failing at the
time.
I don't think he knew he was gonna die
only a few months later,
but in a lot of ways if you watch it
knowing that he perhaps thought it was
his last special,
it brings it to a whole other level
because he ends it.
Really just wrapping up,
like wrapping up a 40 year.
Here's what I think about everything.
It's,
it's pure brilliance.
Well,
he did a new special every year,
so when you have that much material,
you're going to have some hits and some
misses.
But he certainly had way more hits and
he had messes.
Sure.
He had,
he had like a five year,
I think sort of low I guess maybe in the
mid nineties or something where I
thought it became just too much about
cursing and whatever.
But beyond that,
that guy,
I think that represented a low in his
life though you.
He had some issues in his own life,
personal life.
But I,
I'm,
when I was referring to was his old
stuff.
If you go back to when he looked like a
weatherman.
Oh,
you're talking about before he became
the George Carlin,
if you go back and put that time capsule
and try to like wash that today,
it's not really that funny.
You know,
who is really interesting.
The old stuff is woody allen.
Woody Allen's also,
first of all,
he's a fucking pervert and his old
stuff.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
Well look at all leaked into his movies,
his strange sexual stuff and young girls
and you know,
you know,
how old was Mariel Hemingway in,
in Manhattan?
She was,
was first off,
she played under age and I don't know
how old she was.
Yeah,
she was like 17 or something.
How old was she?
She was,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter,
but yeah.
Umm,
but comedy isn't in a weird way.
Like here's,
here's a good example.
Uh,
Eddie Murphy raw at the time was like
this monster standup thing that
everybody had to see.
Oh my God,
I saw it.
I was crying.
Try watching that today.
First of all,
you want to talk about homophobia,
homophobia,
but violently aggressively homophobic.
Yeah.
Which is really weird when you consider
all the allegations that have surfaced
since with him and transgender people
and transsexuals and picking up hookers
that were men like it's.
It's very,
very strange.
Isn't it funny that we try to get.
Look at Oscar Wilde said,
you know,
if you want to tell people the truth,
you have to be funny.
I think it was asking about.
Maybe it was lily Tomlin.
My total.
It's something I can't remember.
One of them,
I don't know how nice man,
but you know,
it's funny that we try as,
as a society,
like so many of the people that of
course that we admired but that everyone
is my are comedians because we're
supposed to tell the truth.
We are supposed to tell the truth and,
and then at the same time,
comedians are often either the sad clown
or severely emotionally crippled or
wanting that approval thing before and
all the lines that you were talking
about and it's a really bizarre place.
So then when you get and you suddenly
get all that approval and then it's
like,
can you still also grow as a human while
you're getting approval for something
that came out of some disfunction and I
know this is the Angeles comedian
discussion,
you have to adjust what,
why you do it,
you know,
you have to do it for other people
instead of doing it for yourself and you
have to do it for the,
for the art,
for the work.
And the work is profoundly enjoyable for
people that love standup.
It's like if you're a painter and you
only paint for yourself,
well you know at a certain point in time
you're running out of shit to paint when
you're painting,
I guess expressing yourself or the
desires of other people.
I think then it becomes different.
Yeah.
I saw George Carlin once just a little
bit before he died also on the view and
he was talking about the art lord poor
man.
Guy took years off his life.
We still have George today if you didn't
make other thing that.
I think he died that later that day.
But he said,
he said something that I thought it was
really great.
He said,
you know,
he said when I became a good comment was
when I got over the need.
Yeah.
And I think that it's a good lesson for
humans in general,
just for people like getting over the
whatever the need is of yourself and we
all struggle with this.
Of course I struggle with it as a person
and as a comic and a host or whatever it
is.
Like we all have that shit and,
and wanting all that approval.
But when you can get over that and just
and really do things for the right clean
reasons and,
and live in and at the same time live in
a way that honors all those things that
you stand up for.
I think that's like the secret,
like that's the,
that's the sauce.
Like that's what we should all be trying
to do at.
And it transcends,
you know,
professional transcends comedy and it
transcends everything pretty much.
Yeah.
I think you're,
I think you're onto it.
And I think also that that process of
like the need is,
is that's the fuel that gets you off the
earth and away from the effects of
gravity and then the momentum of that
sort of carries you on,
but you don't necessarily have to keep
that fucking jet engine fire under your
asshole all the time.
It's.
But that doesn't,
that explained sorta like a white angst
and being fucked up or whatever it is.
You know,
when they say comics are all fucked up
or whatever,
you need a certain amount of that.
Oh you do.
To get going,
you know.
And for a look,
I did stand up.
Think about
this.
I did stand up.
We've only known each other for whatever
it is,
two hours now.
I just signed up for about 10 years in
the closet now.
I was mostly doing political stuff and
social stuff.
It wasn't like I wasn't like outwardly
lying all the time and being like,
ah,
fuck this chicken that,
you know,
like it wasn't like that.
But like I constantly was avoiding the
truth onstage or if,
you know,
if I was getting heckled,
there were easy ways that I would insert
it.
Implied that I was straight or,
and I'm sure time,
I'm 100 percent sure there were times
that I made it seem like I was straight
or something like that,
but that,
that angst and that fuel really made me
successful really quick.
Like I was passed at the comedy cellar
like a year into doing standup and then,
and then a couple of years later,
like it basically all crumbled on me
because I realized that my life,
my person life was way behind where my
art was.
And then I ended up doing gay shows,
which was another fucking nightmare
because if you're a gay comic,
they have one at every club,
right?
Like there's,
there's sort of one like stereotypical
gay comic.
And then suddenly I was the gay comic
and I don't act that gay,
whatever the hell that means.
So I wasn't even gay enough for them.
And I ended up.
Then I ended up on a gay TV channel on
here TV,
which was this like premium gay channel,
and then I ended up on the gay channel
on Sirius Xm.
I want to talk about politics and
instead I was fucking interviewing real
housewives and all that shit and it had
nothing to do with anything I wanted to
do.
Everybody's path is crazy and weird.
Well,
your paths always going to be crazy and
weird because we're human beings and I
think you,
you've,
you're onto it as far as like this
fucked up aspect of you that needs love
so badly.
You want to go on stage with a spotlight
on you and a microphone to amplify your
voice.
Pay attention to me.
Then once you get to that position,
it's up to you to figure out the trick
because if you're a music a magician and
you believe that you're really pulling a
rabbit out of a fucking hat,
you're an idiot.
You know,
like you're,
you're the guy with the trick and the
trick is you know your voice is
amplified.
You're on the stage.
You figured out the cadence and the
hypnotic rhythm in order to get people
to laugh at your stuff,
but what?
What?
What are you actually trying to do?
If you're still trying to fill holes,
will you?
You fucking missed it,
son.
That's just supposed to get you to the
dance and once you're at the dance,
then it's supposed to be about creating
the art and it's supposed to be about
trying to figure out what is the best
way to make something really funny?
What is the best way to make something
so I.
I contribute to culture.
I contribute to people's entertainment
value.
They go out,
they can say,
hey,
Dave Rubin has had the ice house
tonight.
Let's go on out and have a good time,
and they leave there and they go,
that was fun.
Oh my God.
That was great.
That's the goal.
The goal is to.
You're changing the way people feel and
you can do that with ideas and you've
got to work them through,
but yeah,
what gets you to the dance and the first
place is you're fucked up past your
angst,
your insecurities.
You're all that shit.
It's a matter of the people that cling
to those things and they'd never get 'em
never get rid of them.
Then they make it and they don't know
what the fuck to do.
So that,
that's the really interesting part to me
because I lived on the upper west,
as I said,
put that microphone closer to you.
You'll hear it more because we can hear
each other.
Yeah.
When I get deep I start leaning into my
left.
Um,
so I lived on the upper west,
which is like a bastion of comedians.
There's just a zillion comics that live
up there.
Seinfeld lived up there and Elayne
boosler lived up there and uh,
Taylor Negron who I met right before he
died,
didn't even know I met him just a couple
of weeks before he was going to do my
show.
He was a great guy,
great,
great guy.
Just a zillion and a lot of younger
comics,
whatever.
But one,
I used to see Greg Giraldo all the time.
He lived a couple blocks away from me.
And so I think you'll find this really
interesting.
I didn't,
I didn't know him personally,
but he knew I was a comic.
We just sort of nod when we were walking
by and uh,
one day I saw him walking,
his two kids,
he had his two young sons hand in hand
and he was walking between them and I
thought,
wow,
here's a guy who I respect as a comic,
like doing good shit.
He's funny,
he's real.
You could always tell there was like
some pain there,
but like doing it,
you know,
he's getting certain chances like I
think he never got like maybe whatever
would have been his big chance,
but like it was,
he was in the mix and respecting.
Anyway.
Then the next day after that I saw him,
I went to Equinox,
was the gym I went to on the upper west
and I saw him there.
He was working out and I was like,
look,
there's a guy just with his kids.
He's working out like it's all seems
like it's working for this guy.
Like it actually gave me hope,
like,
oh,
I can become like a functioning person
that weekend,
that weekend he was dead.
I mean,
I don't know enough about him.
Well,
I know him and it was,
it was a pill thing was a drug thing,
you know,
and that's,
I'm incredibly unfortunate.
I knew him when he had a television show
because when Greg had,
he,
he had a show,
um,
because,
you know,
Greg started out as a lawyer and he had
a show on one of the networks.
I think NBC,
I don't think so because I was on NBC at
the time and I don't think we're on the
same network.
I think it was ABC,
but it doesn't matter what matters is we
were on the same lot.
We're both on that sunset gower lot that
I was talking about and we were next
door to each other.
So I'd hang out with them,
you know,
we're just fellow comics,
and that's the bond that we shared is
it,
you know,
he had a lot more responsibility than me
because I was on this giant ensemble
where I was the fifth or sixth person on
the.
When the credits roll,
you know,
it'd be like Phil Hartman or Dave Foley,
Mauritania.
So I had no pressure,
but he,
he had the Greg Giraldo show,
I don't remember what it was called,
but it was,
it was his show and he went from that
and then he was really a big part of
tough crowd with Colin Quinn.
And there's that great moment where he's
shut down.
Dennis leary on tough crowd is like one
of my all time favorite moments on tough
crowd because Dennis was getting upset
that Greg Geraldo had written jokes.
He had funny things
to say about certain things.
He goes,
yeah,
a Dennis.
That's what we do.
We write it,
write jokes.
And it was just a classic moment with
Dennis is wearing sunglasses inside.
Greg's like in the prime and Dennis has
come in just horse shit.
Yeah.
Um,
but he,
he was a guy that I think was really
respected by a lot of other comedians
and was really good at roasts and in
today's Day,
you know,
I mean,
he died a few years back.
He probably would be just right now
crushing it like bill burris.
It'd be right now like be in his stride
because I think that what he was doing
and what he was was really good.
Yeah.
But that,
that goes to that.
Thanks man.
Demons.
I mean think about that.
Literally the day before,
and I'm looking at this guy going,
holy shit,
he's doing it.
That pill demon is a different,
different monster than the,
the opiate addict.
You know,
that's a different monster.
the,
the person who does meth or coke or you
know,
the people that go hard as a totally
different monster.
Yeah.
It scares the shit out of me,
man.
I mean I smoked a ton of pot in my day,
like pot yesterday.
I got my card a couple of weeks ago
actually.
I went to the four slash 20 doctor on
melrose.
Wanted to get a prescription,
isn't it?
I thought I'd have to go through a
battery of tests.
Oh my God.
It was like a day of like probing and I
thought I was being taken by joking.
By the way,
folks,
you want to be a fucking idiot to not
get a prescription.
So I could not believe how easy it was.
I went in,
I literally,
I was like,
ah,
well I guess like,
I just wanted weed to smoke weed.
I don't have any real physical elements,
but I was like,
I'll tell him I get headaches,
my knees hurt after I play basketball,
back pain.
I mean the woman looked at me like,
shut the fuck up.
And then I went into.
I had never been to one of the stories.
One of the dispensary's went in there
for.
I still can't believe I've only been
there a couple of times now,
but I can't believe like just the level
of,
it's a real salesperson,
you know,
candy and edibles and oil,
careful.
She wanted oils and uh,
uh,
so there's oils with a wax.
I was like,
you have any weed and weed for him.
Like is there any,
is that it left anymore?
Like,
just some bud.
So I got,
I got oil so it's all there.
It's available.
But yeah,
the problem is once you,
uh,
once you go down to the first floor,
you want to go,
what?
Is there a basement then?
Yes,
there is a basement.
What's that door in the basement.
That's the sub basement.
Let's look in the sub basement and then
you start going deep and next thing you
know you're in a spiral staircase.
I have.
How much pot these smoke?
Um,
I spoke a fair bit depending upon
whether or not I'm at the comedy store
or not.
I enjoy getting high and going to the
comedy store.
I like to get high before I do Jujitsu.
I liked to get high before I give the
misses a stabbing.
Nice to get high before I get an
isolation tank.
Isolation tank.
I want to talk about that.
I liked,
I,
I enjoy marijuana.
Yeah,
that's one of my friends.
So I,
yeah,
I can tell you lit up.
It was great.
You know.
So also I'd like the fact that I
represent the opposite of the
stereotype.
You know,
you're doing shit.
Yeah.
I don't buy it.
I don't buy that.
Marijuana makes you lazy.
I think you're fucking lazy.
I think you could be lazy and,
and eat cheetos.
Does that mean cheetos make you lazy?
You can be lazy and watch TV.
Does that mean TV makes you lazy?
I don't buy it.
I think we're looking for some reasons
why people have flaws and their
personality and I don't think you could
say it's marijuana because marijuana
have all good aspects to it know,
like many things.
It's,
it has good and bad.
The bad thing is the memory,
the memory thing is a bad thing.
Like what,
what were we talking about?
But that's fleeting,
you know,
like longterm memory,
long term memory is fucking fantastic.
It has to be because of the UFC.
Look,
I have a,
a bio when I do the UFC,
which uh,
will tell me like a fighters record tell
me who they're training with and tell
me.
But when the matches are going on,
I'm not leafing through papers.
If I start talking about a fight that
happened seven years ago in another
organization,
it's because it's in my head,
you know,
and when I talked to people and they're
like,
what kind of preparation do you do?
I'm like,
I'm not doing any preparation,
the preparation that I am,
but I'm not the preparation that I'm
doing.
I would do anyway.
I want to watch their fights because I
know they're coming up so I'll wash
their shit if I need to know about some
of their training methods,
but those,
those are things that I will do because
I'm curious about.
I want to,
I want to broaden my understanding of
what their preparation is that because I
want to enjoy the fight more and I enjoy
the fight more if I do that and then I
expressed that,
but all that stuff is off memory.
It's there.
Yeah.
So when I'm doing like how much,
how many notes do you have in front of
you that I write zero on one.
So if you hear me talking about old
matches and stuff like that,
all that shit is in my head because I
have to have good memory and if I really
thought that pot was fucking with that,
I would stop smoking pot but it doesn't
but it will fuck with like.
Well we just talked about.
Yeah,
I know that it'll do that.
What do you think twitter is doing that
too?
I'm a firm believer in that,
that all of these things and having this
phone constantly,
that that's framing.
I mean I'm talking really just splitting
and disintegrating people's memory and
especially short term memory.
I see on my show all the time now.
Anyone will,
beyond just talking about anything that
suddenly they forget what they're
saying.
I'm not talking about 70 year old
people.
I'm talking about a 30 year old people.
You know,
there used to be a time if you were
going to meet a buddy out for are you
going to meet a girl for a drink or
something?
You're waiting on a corner and she's
going to be.
She's five minutes late.
You'd have to stand there and just.
Yup.
And wait.
Think about some shit.
Look at the sky and the people watching
whatever,
but now you immediately,
you immediately do it.
You can immediately scroll and see an
approval,
approval abroad.
They loved me,
they love me,
they hate me,
they love me.
Whatever it is and all of that.
And it goes to what we started with this
whole thing about and six second videos
and all of the shit and this bounce back
of why people like this now is because
all of this I really think is they've
done studies where it's actually
rewiring synopsis and all of this stuff.
It's changing people's brains,
uh,
and that the Internet is actually having
a physical effect on us that's not just
starting next or hungover and done neck
thing is real man.
They're worried that
people are gonna like older people of
our generation and before or are going
to have real issues with their neck
because they're always looking down.
And that in looking down like that
you're stretching the ligaments and
stretching your neck and putting
pressure on your discs.
Even when I'm holding my ipad I feel
like I've done something to my pinky.
Pinky has like,
I'm not kidding,
like I've got like two little
indentations here because I'm holding
this thing all the time like this,
you know,
I mean really people,
you do all kinds of weird shit.
How if you're writing,
I'm a lefty.
So like if I'm writing like I have a
little indentation on my index finger
because the power is always in there,
like you actually can physically change
your body by
some of this technological
unquestionable.
I used to have a from writing from
drawing.
I used to have a big callus on the
inside of my fuck.
You finger on my right a little extra.
Well it was not,
it was not that,
but I mean it's just from.
I drew like hours and hours every day
when I was young and I always had these
big calluses all over there and they've
all gone away.
Now.
It's interesting how that happens.
But to start drawing again.
Yeah,
maybe.
But the neck thing is a real,
real concern.
The,
I think it's gotten me,
I mean obviously your eyes degenerate as
you get older.
That's the thing about close vision.
But with me,
I think it's got to be connected at
least somewhat to staring at screens.
I know that's bad for your focusing on
any short term,
like something that's really close to
you.
And who the fuck was it?
That was on the podcast that referred to
it as like a cast.
I don't remember who it was.
Oh,
it was a short term memory.
Come on.
Who is,
who sleeps on the ground?
Remember the chick who,
uh,
she doesn't sleep on beds and she's got
this interesting.
Cathy is her name.
Cathy.
Um,
what Jamie,
you'll find it.
But anyway,
the way she described it as she was
saying that when you're staring Kathy
Bowman.
Yep.
Yeah.
Katy Bowman.
Thank you.
She that she said when you were staring
at one distance all the time,
just treating your face and your laptop
or your face in your phone is that your
eyes are supposed to look at clothes,
things and far things and look at this
broad range of distances and instead
you're only looking at something right
in front of your face and it fucks with
literally shape of your eye.
And then it's your,
your,
your body doesn't know what the fuck to
do.
I mean,
think about it.
Our grandparents or even our parents.
Well,
my dad was born.
There was no such thing as television.
I'm 39 years old.
That's insane,
right?
So our grandparents had no screens that
didn't even have radio,
right.
Radio just maybe started,
whatever.
It wasn't a window radio started giving
you.
Right.
Okay.
So my grandparents were wars.
Is that 19 twenties?
Yeah.
So I mean really think about that,
how we've changed 100 years and as you
were talking about earlier about how the
Internet's going to change us and we're
learning so much more faster and all
that,
but now it's so involved in this
digital.
I mean it's,
the matrix is becoming real.
Ultimately we're just the batteries for
these things to keep going,
you know,
like they were just putting information.
We're putting whatever our spirit is,
whatever,
whatever you want to call that is just
the battery for this digital thing to
exist.
Do you know who Marshall Mcluhan says?
I don't think so.
Fascinating thinker,
an author from the fifties and sixties,
I think it was,
and he,
he was a part of a.
It was a part of the counterculture and
a lot of ways a lot of people quote
them,
but one of the things that he said about
this is technology before computers,
he said human beings are the sex organs
for the machine world and the idea that
we exist to create these machines and I
firmly believe that what we're doing is
we are some sort of a technological
caterpillar and we're giving birth to a
new life form.
I really,
really believed that and I think that
Elon Musk and what he said about
summoning the demon in the form of
artificial intelligence,
I don't think that's off at all.
I think there's gonna come a time,
whether it's 100 years or a thousand
years,
human life and this biological,
the biological limitations of our own
cellular bodies.
It's going to be ridiculous.
We're,
we're gonna.
We're just gonna.
Get rid of them.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't think it's gonna be that long.
100 or if I forget if that was,
that was,
we're going to be long gone from this
earth.
I don't even think people won't be
around a thousand years.
Uh,
I think we'll have,
I think,
no,
I think a lot of people are probably
going to die here on our dying planet
and you know,
rich people mainly are going to be able
to escape with spaceships.
Yeah.
We're going to go to.
Are we going?
We're going to lie.
I guess we've given up on the moon right
now.
We're going to,
but we're going to go.
We're going to find something.
We're going to find something that has
some of the basic building blocks of
life like earth,
you know,
look,
you know Carl Sagan,
our,
our son is not spectacular by any
stretch and we know that there's
billions and billions of sons in this
galaxy and this university,
you know,
that whole thing and it endlessly
extrapolates and all we are just a tiny
rock with that had the right distance
from the sun and the right amount of
chemicals to make all this shit happen.
We're going to find something that's
going to be similar to this,
but maybe it'll,
it'll all be 10 degrees hotter.
And because of that,
everything will have evolved slightly
differently.
Or maybe you know,
you could pick like I love star wars,
you can pick any of those planets,
you know,
it just evolved differently.
There'll be a planet that's know mostly
water and will have to eventually learn
how to deal with that unless the guys
get here first and kill us,
but possible to that is possible
spoke.
But I think that our own biological
limitations are on organisms are so
acutely adapted to this environment,
the environment of planet earth that it
would be insanely difficult for us to
colonize another planet and insanely,
insanely problematic when it comes to
dealing with whatever life has already.
They're dealing with the environment
dealing with that.
It'd be better to just fix this spot.
Well,
I hope we fucking falling apart.
Like we're like,
we have a shitty old car and we're like,
let's just abandon it and leave it on
the lawn and move to the neighbor's
house.
I mean that's really the idea,
but the neighbor's house is on fire all
the time and it gets pelted with
asteroids.
I think we're going to put all of our
effort into flying to some other planet
and on the way there their son's going
to Supernova and then we're going to
blow up in the middle of space and I'll
hope will be lost.
That's what I think people have been
inspired by this conversation and now
you've people back here on earth.
We're just going to regroup and go,
you know what?
Let's stop trying to go to space and
just clean the ocean.
Yeah.
I really think are something about
humans.
Something about look right now,
like even if we cut,
and again I'm not a scientist,
we'd even when we cut our greenhouse
gases here in America and we do all this
stuff,
India,
these developing nations,
China,
they're going through what we went
through 60 years ago.
So when we have the UN meet and try to
get everybody to come up with numbers
that we're going to allow to put out
this much smog and this much.
All this bullshit.
It's like,
what right do we have to tell them not
to do everything they can to advance
just the way we did 50 years ago.
So.
No.
So it's funny and I live in West
Hollywood.
There are no plastic bags.
Right.
And they don't even want to give me a
paper bag at trader Joe's anymore.
You know,
you have to pay for it,
you have to pay for it.
And that's.
I mostly just pay for paper bags at this
point.
They hate me too because I never bring
my own bag.
I'm a fucking bad ass.
I pay that ten cents for that.
They hate you for that.
Yeah,
you can see it.
The judge,
the horrible judge.
I need those paper bags.
I use the paper bags.
Recycling in them.
Yeah.
Well that's also how I light the fire.
When I use my grill,
I stuffed the paper bag underneath the
little charcoal chimney I use.
Yeah.
Well they'd hate you for that.
Oh fuck them.
Short sided bitches.
Yeah.
Anyway,
the.
I just think the,
the earth.
I Dunno,
I dunno.
I think 100 years they'd be hard for me
to believe that things could still be
going on around here.
Well,
100 years ago,
you'd be amazed at what progress has
taken place.
Socially.
You'd be amazed.
I mean,
think about that.
Think about 18,
65 was the last time slavery was legal,
right?
Think of that.
I think that's an awful long time.
Long time ago now.
That's almost 100 years.
Exactly.
From when I was born.
I was born in [inaudible] 67,
so 102 years later I was born after
sleep,
but that's nothing.
A 100 years is not that much time.
I think that a thousand years from now
who the fuck knows what kind of
technological capabilities we're going
to have as far as our ability to not
just not create waste,
but to use up all the waste that we have
created and use it in a positive way.
Just because you burn gasoline,
it creates pollution.
It doesn't mean that's the only way you
can get energy and just because
pollution is in the air,
carbon dioxide is hitting record levels.
It doesn't mean that can't be maintained
and regulated.
I think there's gotta be a way that
people can figure out how to live
sustainably if it's possible to live
sustainably in a small community.
It's possible to live sustainably
globally,
so when you do it for yourself,
like
when you hunt for your meat and you were
Tommy,
have chickens before.
When you.
When you do all that stuff,
do you feel that you're doing it for
yourself or you're doing it for your
community or is it 50 slash 50
zero and be totally honest?
Zero for my community,
zero for the earth.
I'm just thinking what's the best way?
This is just my,
my intent going in.
I understand that it's better for the
earth,
but my intent going in is like I don't
want to rely on other people for my
food.
I don't want to rely on some farmer to
not shove antibiotics and hormones and
the food.
I want to be able to eat clean,
healthy food.
Also,
ethically,
I don't want to be a part of the factory
farming system.
I think when I watch these youtube
videos,
he's peta videos on how they raised pigs
and cows and it's fucking evil.
I'd rather shoot a wild pig.
I'd rather.
I'd rather eat moose,
you know,
I think it's better for you to the
protein wise,
the protein content of elk and Moose is
far higher than the protein content of
beef.
It's better for you.
You can eat smaller portions.
You get more out of it.
I just,
for me,
it gives me a better feeling.
I know where everything came from when I
eat a steak that I cut from an elk
myself.
That is such a different feeling than
when you go to the supermarket and you
get something of ambiguous origins and
plastic wrapped container and just take
it home and cut open a plastic and slap
it on the grill and.
Or I'm out here growing locker man.
So you know
trader Joe's that when you get just
chopped me from trader Joe's,
it comes from four different countries.
They have four countries of origin on
it.
For beef,
for beef,
go right now.
Countries.
Yeah.
You could go.
Maybe we can google it,
the that it,
it's coming from,
you know,
United States,
something like the United States,
Canada,
Mexico,
and then like something that we're not
even geographically connected to and
then I guess they package it all here.
But think about that like,
you know how we're so disconnected from
our food that when you eat a freaking
burger from trader Joe's,
it came from for country.
I'm not making this up.
We,
I believe you.
I didn't think.
I wouldn't think you were making it up,
but I shouldn't say I'm surprised
because if it's cheaper to do it that
way,
that's how they're going to do it.
In trader Joe's is known for having
fairly inexpensive food.
Shouldn't say cheap because it's all
good,
but like whole foods,
one of the things that are like about
whole foods,
people say whole foods is expensive.
It is expensive,
expensive,
but they'll show you like the farm where
the beef is being grown and you can
choose how you want it.
Like you can choose,
like I did a bordain show the other day.
We're,
we're hunting pheasants in Montana for
an upcoming episode and we were talking
about steak and he was like,
you know what I mean?
Everybody says,
Oh,
you have to have grass fed,
grass fed.
He goes,
I like a fatty steak.
I like steak.
That's a.
That eats corn I think.
I think it tastes better and a lot of
ways,
but they give you options.
They give you.
That whole tiered system shows you
exactly where the meat is coming from,
how it's.
There's a fucking photo of the farm,
like they show you the farm where these
things are being raised in,
in.
It's more expensive to eat sustainable
food.
It is.
It's more expensive.
These hunts that I go on doesn't cheap.
The effort is way more.
I mean if I,
if I shoot an elk,
it's gonna take me five or six days to
put it all together to get one and then
you have to process to mean Carey and
freeze it.
And do you do all of that or do you have
people?
I assume you have somebody helping you.
It depends on.
Some of them have done all of it on,
on,
on other ones.
If I'm traveling,
I'm flying.
What I can do is do a lot of it and then
bring the remaining pieces,
a quarter it and bring the quarters to a
meat processor and ask them to turn it
into steaks or turning into sausage or
have things like that done.
But the big cuts like the back straps
and the tenderloins and stuff like that.
I do all that myself.
The heart and the liver.
I cut all that stuff out myself and then
I bring it with me.
I freeze it and you know,
if you want to see how crazy the food
system is.
Also you could check,
you know,
there's so many documentaries on this,
but the amount of laws that we have that
protect the factory farming from simple
things like having cameras in where the
chickens are illegal,
things that purdue is getting away with.
I always think purdue to me is like the
worst of the worst because if you watch
their commercials,
and this goes to what we were talking
about with the,
with the drugs and the happy people
during the day and then they're having
diarrhea and killing each other,
whatever,
like the,
the,
the purdue commercials.
You've got this guy come out,
he's hanging out with chickens,
you know,
he's talking to them.
Oh there is Bernadette.
And did they still have.
They still do all that stupid shit he
was.
Or sometimes it's a cartoon and he walks
in the morning.
What he doesn't say is that he just,
he's about,
you know,
it's like a Holocaust is going on in
there.
He's killing all the chickens and he's
going to kill them,
but we have somehow like that's how
marketing is so crazy.
We don't let cameras in to watch them
rip the beaks off and not let them in.
It's illegal.
So think about that and can get
arrested.
What does that have to do?
Why would the government,
why would our government that's supposed
to have our best interests at heart?
Right.
I guess that's the government supposed
to have a.
Why would they pass that kind of law?
A lot of money to be made.
Exactly.
If you want to go to General Motors and
you want to film them putting together a
Camaro,
of course love it.
They look at what the tour is,
how we do it,
why?
Because no fucking babies are getting
crushed other making Camaro's,
but if you want to go to a pig farm and
film it,
you can go to jail.
Like these are new laws that have been
passed because of whistleblowers and
those laws are evil.
That's evil.
I mean that should be transparent.
One hundred percent.
You should be able to know exactly where
your food is coming from.
There's only one way to do that.
Yeah.
I mean we've done so many things between
feeding these animals,
all sorts of shit that they shouldn't be
eating.
Have you ever drove,
drove up?
I think it's a five.
If you're driving up towards San
Francisco.
He passed Harris ranch,
Harris ranch.
I think if I'm not mistaken,
it's the largest.
A meat producer in the United States are
the largest meat producing ranch in the
United States,
and when you pass it,
they call it cow shit.
I mean,
that's how there is so much.
It stinks of death.
I mean pure death,
right?
You've smelled that for a good mile or
two.
You can see it in the air.
You see these dirty animals that can
barely move.
I mean,
I love meat on my twitter from last
night I had grass fed steaks cooked on a
whole Himalayan salt plate.
I love me.
Right?
But after that I was like,
Jesus,
like this is serious.
That's when I got on at least doing the
grass fed free range thing.
Well,
this is like,
I can't be part of this,
but I know it's about money.
Well,
it's not just about money.
It's about volume.
Like when you have a community of 20
million people across Los Angeles and
none of them are growing their own food.
Yeah,
they're going to need food and where's
that food going to come from?
It's going to come from somebody else
that grows up food and we'll how they're
going to grow that food.
They're going to grow that food in the
most cost effective and efficient way
possible,
which means stuff.
These fucking animals into these cages.
Unless you demand something different
and well,
if you do demand something different,
you're going to have a higher price
because then these companies aren't
going to be making much money,
so they're going to have to charge more
money for the meat and then people can
afford it and then it becomes a problem.
But if you wanna be able to go to in and
out burger or in and out.
It's not a good example because it takes
a little time,
but like Jack in the box,
pull in,
get up,
ground up beef sandwich within 30
seconds.
Yeah,
look,
there's only one way to do that.
You know,
you got to do it with a massive factory.
You have to be churning these fuckers
out,
hanging above their ankles and putting
pest piston,
you know,
through their brain every 30 seconds.
I mean that's.
That's got to be chunk,
chunk,
chunk.
You got to be constantly wiping them out
because there's so many people that are
hungry.
How do you think we get people to wake
up on this?
Because what we did,
we covered.
We covered on my show.
Sometimes it's one of the things that I
bring on camera to talk about our food
sources and the way that these,
you know,
you were eating sick animals and then we
wonder why we're sick.
Like it's all.
Of course it's all connected.
You open up a thing of meat and it's
great.
Why is it great?
Why would you put that in your.
Why would you put that in your body?
But this is one of those things.
It's like our,
the level of our discourse in America
and the level of the nonsense on cable
news and they can keep us distracted
with Kim Davis issues and they can't
keep us distracted with all of this
nonsense and I don't think it's
necessarily like some big conspiracy of
keeping us distracted as much as it's
what we are as humans is this endless
distraction.
There's just this endless distraction
and you got a pill for some truth out of
it.
You gotTa Pill for some way to find
something that works for you,
so I don't know that they can ever fix
it because it's.
We're just in it.
I don't even know if it's an endless
distraction.
I think that life has too many
variables.
It's almost impossible to consider all
the variables,
so you're going to build your own
shelter,
you're going to figure out your own
electricity,
you're going to run your own wires.
Are you going to fix your own washing
machine?
You're gonna build your own washing
machine.
You know what?
Where are you going to get it?
We're going to get the parts.
Are you going to the metal?
It's like there's so
many things involved with living a
comfortable healthy life in 2015 in the
city that you're going to be responsible
for all aspects or just is it just going
to be food sourcing?
What about sewage?
What about waste disposal?
What are you going to do about all that
stuff?
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
Look into that or you just going to like
flush your shit down the toilet and hope
the guy at the other end knows what to
do.
That's essentially what it boils down
to.
This super complicated civilization that
has been created.
You can say we've created,
but it's we're,
we're riding on the momentum of the
people that came before us and those
people that came before is oftentimes
didn't know what the fuck they were
doing.
Didn't plan for the future.
Certainly didn't think that mean when I
was a kid in the 19 seventies there was
like $100,
million less people in this country
think.
Just think about that.
Think about the numbers between like
1975 and 2015.
There's more than.
I think it's more than $100,
million more people just in this kind of
baby boomers had all those kids.
It's insane.
And then there's India that's exploding
population of China.
Massive population to the point where
they're,
they're trying to limit the amount of
babies that people have.
I mean,
we live in a very,
very strange time in that people are
awakening to all the problems that have
been created by this massive amount of
people and this incredible need for
resources,
but at the same time you're working
eight hours a day plus plus commuting,
plus hobbies plus sexual needs and
entertainment needs and friendships and
every poll and push and oh well you've
got to have civic responsibility.
Guess what,
Dave Rubin,
we need you for jury duty.
You can't catch up.
And we,
we,
we operate on this fucking constant
momentum with very little quiet time and
that's things that I love to this thing.
That's what I loved the most about those
sensory deprivation tank because I get
that quiet time that you don't get,
you know,
I get,
I get time for reflection.
How often?
How often are you doing it?
Well,
I have it in my house.
Oh Man.
So I do it all the time.
Wow.
That is really cool.
Yeah,
I think everyone should do it.
Just to try,
just to feel what it's like to just be
alone with your thoughts because it's
the only time you're actually alone with
your thoughts because you're not.
Your body isn't even registering.
Is there a lock on that thing?
No.
I would be freaking out the entire time.
No,
I know,
but doesn't make sense,
but like would there be some reason that
it could lock?
No.
Yeah.
I was not even a latch.
There's not even a door handle or
anything.
It just pushes open and push his clothes
got.
How long do you go in there?
For?
As long as I want.
Usually at least an hour usually,
but sometimes two hours.
I know for the first 20 minutes of being
in there,
I'd be like,
is this thing locked?
Did I get lost?
Like it would be a lot.
Even if I was alone,
I would just be fearing.
That's funny.
You'd get used to it.
It's like everything else.
It's not scary at all.
It's relaxing.
What is one of those run yet?
It's expensive.
A cheap one for like.
Well,
I think there's a company called Zen
float that makes a small personal one
that Duncan has in his house.
I think that one is still fairly
expensive,
but it's like 1500 bucks.
I got the top of the line.
Bad Mama Jama float lab version,
which is like 30 grand.
Wow.
Really expensive.
But mine is seven feet tall,
nine feet wide and it looks like a meat
locker.
It's like it looks like a gigantic
freezer that you step into,
but it's perfect.
I'd like to see the compound that you
live on.
I feel like there's a lot of cool
between the chickens slash and there's
elk.
Yeah.
Before archery range because that's 100
yards in my yard.
Rubber pigs and rubber elk and I have an
ikea couch.
Yeah,
I built it.
I don't want to.
I don't want to brag,
but it's an l pretty,
pretty sweet.
I was reading this thing that was a.
They were talking about people they
experience more satisfaction in the
ownership of things like Ikea because
even though it's not like good
furniture,
it's not like the best furniture.
The fact that they put it together
themselves gives them a sense of
satisfaction that I think we're kind of
missing and part of our culture,
like someone who built their own house
and built their own furniture and they
sit in their own house,
their own furniture probably gets like a
deep feeling of satisfaction about that.
Well,
I can tell you as someone that has
almost all Ikea,
you know,
it's funny.
It's taken me.
I started,
I'm 39.
I started standing up and right when I
got out of college,
Ninety eight had radio shows.
Like it's been a long,
long journey.
I finally,
for the first time in this past,
it's really in the past six months and
only in the last couple months that I
really feel like I'm sort of on the
other side for the first time and I know
that that feeling never goes away and I
probably just jinxed it on your side.
And what went well.
The other side meaning like I feel like
I've,
I'm here somewhere like I'm in the
career.
Like I really have something and know
what I'm saying and know what I'm doing.
And being rewarded for it financially
and personally and by my audience and
stuff.
But I'm not rolling in dough by,
by any stretch.
I'm going to make six figures but like,
but I'm doing good.
Right.
You're not scared.
I'm not.
Yeah.
But the fear,
it's always there.
The fear factor,
so to speak.
I think it probably never leaves the
moon.
I have a friend of mine who's on a huge
Sitcom.
She's making a boat load of money and
she talks to me about it all the time.
She's like,
it could be gone tomorrow and then what?
And then what am I left it.
So I have some money now,
but like,
you know,
what am I left with?
Um,
but I do aspire my,
my house is pretty much 90 percent Ikea.
Like I want to get to 100.
No,
I want to get to the point when there's
no,
I want to get to 10 percent.
I mean like my couch is Ikea.
My bed is Ikea,
my futons,
Ikea.
The Shit in my kitchen is Ikea.
Like that would be to me success like
designer furniture.
But because the ikea couch more than
anything is,
is painful.
Not Good.
It's not good.
No.
That might be what my neck hurts.
It's not because of my.
I be that as well.
Yeah.
But that.
But,
but you know like I'm but also like
there's
a lot of truth in that like that.
I feel like it's sort of started working
and I was just looking around my place
the other day.
Like maybe the next phase will be like a
little bit more something.
Well I feel like it's a rabbit hole that
you have.
You have to be really careful when they
step in because it will suck your time
up.
This hunting thing suck my time up.
If I went into the manufacturing my own
furniture thing,
like doubting my own wood and milling it
and so and unfortunately I have friends
that are professional woodworkers,
you know,
I,
I know like that.
It is possible to learn all that stuff
and then build furniture.
You could do it,
but then you'd have to say,
okay,
well am I going to weave my own cloth to
cover this furniture?
You turn it on your own butter.
I mean,
what are we talking about?
Going to use the elk that I killed for
the leather that covers the couch and
I'm going to have to kill quite a few
animals to populate my house.
The whole thing would be a blood bath,
nuts,
a lot of work.
So a lot of work.
Or am I going to get one of them crazy
Indian weaves,
you know,
when you'd like to have the yarn,
you pull it through and you push it down
and make your own cloth.
Yeah.
It's a lot of fucking words.
Do you feel like you're there and that
place,
that place on the other side where
you've sort of built what you wanted to
build and,
and your life and your work and all of
the sort of lined up?
No,
I don't think that,
yeah,
I might think like that.
I don't worry about money.
Yeah,
don't worry about money.
But um,
I worry about work in,
in that I want to make sure that
everything I'm doing is good.
Whether it's podcasts or whether it's
stand up or whether it's doing my
commentary.
I always want to make sure that I'm not
doing bad stuff and that if I,
if I have done something that's not that
good,
I make sure that that doesn't happen
ever again or that if it does happen
again.
I learned from that one too and then it
gets better even there.
So there's that.
Like,
it's not like shit I gotta pay my bills,
but I do remember that feeling bad and I
also remember the moment that that went
away.
How free it was.
Like I got a development deal when I was
like,
I don't know how many years in economy,
but it's like 93 and I got a big check
from Disney of all people and all of a
sudden I didn't have to worry about how
I was paying my rent all of a sudden for
at least the next year or so,
or a couple of years it was paid and it
was like this silence,
like this weight.
Just literally a physical weight lifted
off my shoulders.
And then I thought about it and I said,
man,
you know what?
Some people never get to that place.
They live their life from cradle to the
grave,
constantly under the pressure of bills,
check to check,
and that that freedom of not worrying
about your bills is massive and people
trip themselves up by putting themselves
in debt and by getting in over their
head,
giving themselves a bunch of shit that
they don't need.
Then they have to pay for it or they buy
it on credit and they have to fucking
don't worry.
I'll figure out a way and that that
pressure is overwhelming for people.
When that pressure went away,
it was replaced by the pressure to try
to do good stuff,
to try to do things that I can be proud
of,
to try to do things.
Where are you doing that already?
Yeah,
but I was trying to do it and I was
worried about making money at the same
time and as soon as the worry about
making money kind of goes away.
Then your.
You're left with a pure sense of why
you're doing it.
So isn't that for all the things that
now we put out there,
podcasts,
video,
audio,
all that stuff.
Owning your brand,
all the.
All the things that you do,
I know I hate it to a boy on your brand.
People say this,
I want to run from them.
Yeah.
How do you manage your brand?
Somebody asked me to do a seminar on
that really recently.
Well,
you're not worried about money,
so I guess he didn't have to be pretty
good.
I don't think you make much money on
those seminars.
Seminars,
pay,
you know who,
who gets money?
The people that run the seminar to the
pimps.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
No,
uh,
but that,
that's the beauty of all this stuff.
So you built this whole thing and then
you're free.
You,
you answered it yourself,
you know,
this is a very unique time for people
like us because finally,
all of this exists so that we can
control our destiny.
You know,
and I'm,
I'm attached to a network or has been
really good to me.
As you said at the beginning.
They let me do whatever I want.
I mean,
literally they sat me down the day
before the show started,
an executive who I'd never met in person
before.
Said he's like,
I have one thing to say to you,
make the show you want to make,
not to show you think we want you to
make.
What is your show on?
What is it on TV?
What does that?
Which is Larry King's digital network.
Larry King has his own digital Mary
King.
It's with partners with Carlos Slim.
Is that Carlos Slim Jim?
They said,
no,
he's not.
He's even richer than that guy.
They say he's the.
He was either the richest or second
richest man in the world.
He's a Mexican telecom billionaire.
Yeah.
He partly.
When's The New York Times now and a
bunch of other stuff.
They're part digital network and part
production company.
So William Shatner as a show there.
Jesse Ventura as a show say.
Well,
I mean,
as I said,
I'm not.
I'm not making six figures like pause
and I'm not making six figures,
but they let me do it at King's almost
dying.
Come crash.
Oh,
oh.
To the hounds.
Yeah.
He's been very good to me.
You know what?
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you what.
I want to hear better numbers.
Believe me.
I want to get better at ovaries do,
but actually this is the first deal that
I ever had my agent close for me and
because I'd always done even my Sirius
xm deals,
I did myself and my podcast deals.
I'd always done everything and when my
agent did this,
it was.
I didn't realize how hard it was going
to be for me to let go and be like,
Oh,
I'm supposed to trust you to actually do
a deal now.
That was really hard for me to actually
say,
you know,
but that's.
But that's how you mature in this thing.
You gotta you gotTa have a good agent.
I told you my issue that I had with the
agent when dementia thing went down,
but I've had the same manager scrub.
I was just a kid in my early twenties to
know what the fuck I was doing that was
able to since I was an open mic.
Wow.
That's where I got really lucky.
My,
he found me in Boston when I was make
people laugh and he saw something that
he thought and we worked together ever
since and we've been.
He's one of my best friends.
He's a great friend,
so,
but because people are,
I think people always confuse her to the
manage your aging thing.
A manager really is sorta like it.
A lot of respects should be your friend
and your guru and you're sort of helping
you down that road.
The agent is getting you gates,
but sometimes they're not.
I mean I have friends that have just
really fucked up relationships with
their managers and when you're not doing
well,
the manager can be a real hard to get on
the fringe,
codependent relationship.
You're saying the people in this town
can be fair weather friends can't
listen.
We're almost out of time,
but I really.
Before we leave a half to talk to you
about one thing that you told me that I
think is when you do start doing well,
then your.
They're your buddy.
Like it's an incestuous reared fucking
very strange codependent relationship.
You're saying that people in this town
can be fair weather friends that we're
listening,
we're almost out of time,
but I really,
before we leave a half to talk to you
about one thing that you told me that I
think is incredibly fascinating.
You came out literally the to someone
for the very first time,
the day before September 11th,
the night it was.
It was about midnight of September 11th,
so meaning September 10th.
It just rolled into September 11th.
The first person ever came out to a
brilliant comic who you've never heard
of and I don't even know what happened
to him.
This guy,
Mike Singer,
was one of the best comics that I ever
knew.
We worked for years together.
Sky was wickedly funny.
I think he lives in Columbia now or
something.
You're not doing standup.
Anyway,
he was gay and he was so.
I in a way,
I was ahead of my time in terms of being
out as a comic that doesn't necessarily
play into every stereotype and all that.
This guy was really ahead of it because
he was 15 years older than me and had
done it already.
Anyway,
we were in the time square subway.
I was going back.
I lived on the upper east at the time.
I was walking to the shuttle thing to go
to get on the east side and I had.
I was just a fucking complete mess.
It's,
it's incredibly hard to live one life to
live one life on this planet is a hard
thing.
Try living too at the same time and
that's what I was doing because I had my
life that everyone knew and then I had
this secret life where I was out,
you know,
hooking up and I was lying to people
constantly.
Even though I never intended to lie.
I would be somewhere and I bumped into a
friend and I'd be with a guy,
a gay person,
and I could just,
oh,
that's my cousin.
Like it just,
it was incredible.
I'd never really,
I mean I never intended to lie to people
or it just became this really horrible
game of cat and mouse and I was
depressed and I was smoking pot and all
this shit anyway.
Um,
and then when it,
when it really,
so that,
as I said earlier,
you know,
that that was the fuel for good comedy
for a long time.
And then eventually it just started
sputtering.
It was like I wasn't happy,
I wasn't full.
I wasn't,
couldn't bring those things to the stage
anymore.
And just my life was a fucking disaster.
Anyway,
about midnight,
just eight hours before the first plane
hit,
I'm in the time square subway station
with my friend.
I told him I was gay.
I don't think he realized even though
this guy knew me for years,
I don't think he realized that.
I don't think I said,
Oh,
you're the first person I'm telling or
something like that.
Like I just said it and we just,
we talked for two or three minutes and
he's like,
all right,
I'll talk to you later this week or
something.
And I go home and I woke up.
I turned on the TV in America is under
attack and I kid you not like I was
smoking a lot of pot at the time.
I was not mentally right.
Like I wasn't.
I remember probably a few weeks before
that I was walking to the subway and by
living two lives I felt I felt like a
crazy person.
It's hard to describe.
The only way I can describe it was I
remember walking down second avenue and
it looked like all the buildings were
shaking like I was.
I felt centered like I was okay,
but literally you'd felt like the world
was being ripped apart.
That was like the,
the level of disconnect I had with
reality at that point.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like if you can't express your love
properly,
if you can't,
you know.
That's why we started this whole thing
talking about all these guys that are
jacked and working out all the time and
whatever.
It's like,
that's what I said.
It's very sad to me because these are
people who could not express a very
human thing in a proper way.
So they end up acting out at 45 in a way
that they should have acted when they
were 15,
partying and having a great Milo
Yiannopoulos.
What do you have against a math?
Well,
Milo,
who you had on a couple of weeks ago and
I had them on the day or two after.
I mean we argued about that.
Me As the liberal,
the gay married liberal who's for that
traditional thing and him as the off the
wall,
British gay,
conservative who's against gay marriage
because he wants to talk about drugs and
partying and sex and whatever.
So that's why I love talking to him in
all honesty.
And I really enjoyed talking to Milo.
He's trolling and so many different ways
simultaneously winking at you the entire
time.
That's the audience.
I think the audience is aware of it.
And if he was sitting right here he
wouldn't answer,
isn't aware of it.
I don't think,
Oh,
these people are idiots.
But anyway,
so I woke up and I,
I kid you not,
Joe,
I kid you not.
I thought it had something to do with
me.
I thought we were like the world was
attacked or we were under attack because
that I finally express this thing that I
had,
the secret that I had had that it was so
bad that being out caused the world to
collapse.
I know that even saying that now,
I've always told this publicly maybe
twice,
like it sounds completely fucking insane
and it's.
That was.
And it is insane.
But like that's where my head was at
and,
and interestingly after that,
the way I dealt with coming out was I
would tell someone and then I would get
this little burst of feeling better.
I would suddenly [inaudible] you.
I was like constricting my heart and
when I would tell someone it would,
it would open up a little and I'd feel
better and I could.
I really could feel like I could breathe
better,
like really felt better.
And then I would wait until that
pressure would start building again.
Sometimes I would wait months and then I
would tell someone and then I would do
this over the course of like two years.
And then eventually I realized,
I was like,
you know,
every time I tell somebody this thing
that I think is horrible and they're
pretty much okay and I feel better,
I was like,
I gotta end this,
it's time to end this now.
And that's,
that's basically when I told the
remaining people.
And that was it.
It's a weird secret because the people
that do care that don't like it,
they're not worth knowing and nobody,
literally nobody,
nobody that I told,
you know,
my dad struggled for a little bit or you
know,
whatever.
This and that.
My a lot.
The thing that mostly people got was
that nobody believed I was gay.
That was like,
my mate,
will you play basketball?
You play basketball,
you know,
like that.
So nobody could believe like they just
don't seem gay.
Like I don't like to dance,
I don't dance.
I learned my dancing from Cosby,
like that's my move,
you know?
So all of that.
So that was the main thing.
Everyone was just sideswiped.
So a lot of times people will say to me,
you know,
you're straight or you're straight
acting or saying,
which in the gay community is thought
of.
It's like this great thing,
you know,
they're a pure,
straight acting your masculine.
It's really great.
But I don't,
I don't take it that way because every
time someone says it to me,
it makes me feel like a freak,
you know what I mean?
Like why am I.
Yeah.
Because I am who I am.
This is it.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like I had gay sex last night after I
had that grass fed beef,
you know?
And so I'm gay,
I'm married to a guy there.
It sounds like a gay person that's a
pretty gay married to a guy would say
that's pretty gay.
That's what I realized.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm marrying this dude.
Like I guess,
but you know what I mean?
That was like,
Holy Shit.
Like I guess,
well,
you know,
turning it back now.
Um,
it was a phase I was renting.
Yeah.
This is a long way.
I'm really like,
you know,
it's dragging out this phase thing,
but I realized that if I felt better
when I told people that,
that there had to be some value in that
in a way that I couldn't understand
things,
but,
but to the,
to the straight acting like it means
nothing to me when I meet guys that are
completely flaming or if I meet guys
that are,
that you'd have no idea.
Like I like people based on their values
and their sense of humor and like shit
like that.
I never asked to all people that matter
as as.
Yeah,
and you know what?
That's a great way to bring this all
around because that gets away from
judging people on what you're supposed
to think about them and all that social
justice warrior and regressive bullshit
versus judging people on the content of
their character and also gets back to
what we're saying earlier that it's like
it's just being aware socially being a
good person to communicate with versus
being socially retarded and just looking
for those Ben Affleck Brownie moment.
Yeah.
Let me toss in one other thing that sort
of ties into this really nicely,
so one one time when I was on the young
Turks,
and I'm not gonna mention names here,
but I was on and they were showing a
clip from Fox News and they were talking
about how the host that he was such a
token black guy.
He was such a token black guy and
actually know the guy.
This guy,
David Webb,
who I used to work with at Sirius Xm.
I'm pretty good friends with him.
I had dinner with him last week.
He is a black conservative.
He is a conservative.
I know him.
I know what this guy believes.
He spends hours on the air every day
professing his beliefs and that's what.
That was another.
This happened a little bit after that
whole Sam Harris thing,
but that was another moment when I
realized how perverse this whole
progressive thing is that here you have
people on the left that are supposed to
be about ideas,
looking at the color of that guy's skin
and saying,
well,
because you don't believe what I think
you're supposed to believe.
As a black person,
you're a token black,
you know,
we've all done that,
like when they showed like a Republican
convention and there's one black I
talking about,
but I realized that's actually racism
like that was.
That was really a seminal moment for me
that really changed my thinking because
I was like,
this is crazy.
I know this person personally.
This is a friend of mine and I know he
believes he's not doing this because
he's a token black.
This is,
this is what he believes,
and you as the on the left are pointing
at this guy and saying,
you're different than what I think
you're supposed to be black guy,
so you must be a token or you're an
uncle tom or a sell out or something.
And also all of this,
when you have the gay stuff,
the social justice or either the
regressive stuff like judge people based
on what they say,
what they say and what they believe.
Nothing else.
That's it.
Wrap it up.
J Dot Reuben.
Thank you very much.
I'm glad we got together.
I've never had to pee as badly as I do
right this second.
I'll run.
If I had peed,
I couldn't.
Just keep going.
Just fine.
People have done it a bunch of times
show.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
This was beyond the pleasure.
How do people listen to your show?
How do they get ahold of that Youtube
Slash Rubin report or a TV or a dot TV
slash Rubin Rubin Report on twitter.
My branding.
I told you at the branding.
Keep that brand alive.
Thanks brother.
Thanks Bro.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back soon and see,
uh,
see,
have a lovely life.
Kiss your friends by,
by weight.
Open the door.